THANK YOU FOR JOINING US AND
LOOK FORWARD TO A PRODUCTIVE
HEARING. AS YOU KNOW DO THE
COVERT NINETEEN WE HAVE LIMITED
ROOM AVAILABLE FOR THE PUBLIC
IN THIS ROOM AND IN ROOM ONE
TWENTY SIX OF THE CAPITAL.
WHICH IS THE WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOM FOR TODAY'S
HEARING. PLEASE BE MINDFUL OF
THE MASS REQUIREMENT FOR
EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM. AND IN
THE ROOM ONE TWENTY SIX AND
MAINTAIN PHYSICAL DISTANCING.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC CAN
PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S HEARING
BY CALLING IN. THE AND THE CALL
IN NUMBER IS ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. THE PIN NUMBER IS
ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN OR BY VISITING THE
COMPANY'S WEBSITE AT ASSEMBLY
DOT CA DOT GOV. AS REQUESTED
WITH THE WITNESSES. ANDAN
PUBLIC COMMENT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS
THAT THE SOMEBODY HAS RULES TO
ENSURE WE MAINTAIN ORDER AND
RUN AN EFFICIENT HEARING. WE
SEEK TO PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF
ALL WHO PARTICIPATE IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS SO THAT CAN
BE EFFECTIVE DELIBERATION AND
DISCUSSIONS ON THE CRITICAL
ISSUES FACING CALIFORNIA. IN
ORDER TO FACILITATE THESE GOALS
WE WILL NOT PERMIT CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE.
IMPEDE THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
LEGISLATIVE PROCEEDINGS IN
ADDITION. THIS YEAR WE WILL
AGAIN BE COMPLYING. WITH ALL
PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS ARISING
OUT OF THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. NO LAST WEEK
CALIFORNIA HAS. WAS HOME TO THE
LOWEST SEVENTY POSITIVELY RIGHT
OF A COVER NINETEEN HOURS IN
THIS COUNTRY STATEWIDE ALMOST
TWELVE MILLION PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
FULLY FASCINATED AND CLOSE TO
SIX POINT FIVE MILLION FOLKS
HAVE BEEN PARTIALLY VACCINATED
AS OF APRIL TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THIS REPRESENTS
OVER 57% OF CALIFORNIA'S
POPULATION OVER THE AGE OF
SIXTEEN. YOUR CASE WILL COVER
NINETEEN HOURS ARE AVERAGING
AROUND. TWO THOUSAND AS OPPOSED
TO A PEAK OF FORTY THOUSAND
CASES A DAY LAST. WINTER DOES
TO RECOVER NINETEEN ARE
AVERAGING UNDER ONE HUNDRED AS
OPPOSED TO A DAILY HIGH OF
CLOSE TO SIX HUNDRED DEATHS. A
DAY OF THE HIGHEST PART OF THE
SEARCH. LAST MONTH THE GOVERNOR
ANNOUNCED JUNE FIFTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE OF THE TARGET TO
FULLY REOPENING CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY. IF CALIFORNIA'S
CONTINUE GET VACCINATED AND
HOSPITALIZATIONS REMAIN LOW THE
STATE IS ON COURSE TO MEET THAT
DATE. AS OF TODAY NOT A SINGLE
COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA WITH THE
STATE'S MOST RESTRICTIVE WASH
FOR TIER AND THE MAJORITY OF
THESE COUNTIES ARE THE MODERATE
OR MINIMAL HERE NOW. THESE
NUMBERS ARE WELCOME NEWS
ESPECIALLY THOSE HAVE BEEN ON
THE FRONT LINES PANDEMIC FOR
WELL OVER A YEAR NOW. OVERALL
THE OUTLOOK IS BRIGHT BUT WE
CAN'T AFFORD TO LET OUR GUARD
DOWN. AS WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
WE RECOGNIZE THE DEPARTMENT
IMPACT OF COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS HAD ON COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR. MOST OF WHOM ARE SENT
TO WORKERS WHO HAVEN'T HAD THE
LUXURY OF WORKING FROM HOME.
THESE FOLKS NOT ONLY ARE GREAT
RISK CONTRACTING THE VIRUS. BUT
THEY OFTEN HUNDRED BALANCE
CHILDCARE AND DISTANCE LEARNING
ON TOP OF THAT AMOUNT IN THE
CENTRA JOBS. IN MANY INSTANCES
THE GREATEST REST OF
COMMUNITIES IN THE DISASTER OF
THE MOST DIFFICULT TO REACH
WITH HELP. THIS HAS BEEN
ESPECIALLY TRUE DURING THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
MAKE PROVIDING AN EQUITABLE
RESPONSE EXTREMELY CHALLENGING.
TODAY WE WILL HAVE AN
INCREDIBLE PANEL TALK WITH
THESE CHALLENGES. ON OUR FIRST
PANEL WE WILL HEAR FROM CHIEF
DARYL OSBY THE LOSS ON COUNTY
FIRE DEPARTMENT. DR ARMY SYSTEM
FROM THE- ACCOUNTING PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT DR PAUL SIMON
FROM BLOSSOMS COUNTY FORMING A
PUBLIC HEALTH. SHEEN ROGOFF
DIRECTOR OF SPECIAL OPERATIONS
GLOBAL MEDICAL RESPONSE. OUR
SECOND PANEL INCLUDE. DR DAVE
DUNCAN DIRECTOR OF EMERGING
MEDICAL SERVICES OF THIRTY.
PREG JOHNSON CHIEF OF DISASTER
MEDICAL SERVICES THEM SO. DR
THOMAS ARGON MEDICAL DIRECTOR
OF STATE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER
CALIFORNIA FORMER PUBLIC
HEALTH. CALIFORNIA OVER. HERE
MASS MERCHANT SERVICES. BEFORE
AGAIN THERE ARE MANY OPENING
MARK FROM THE VICE CHAIR AND
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SO THAT AND WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT TWENTYMEMBERS NO.
THANK YOU FOR TODAY'S HEARINGS
UNTIL THE END THANK FOR
TRANSPARENT AND PLEASE HOLD AND
QUESTION TO THEM. WITHOUT THE
STRICKEN WITH OUR FIRST PANEL-
CHIEF OSBY LIKE TO BEGIN. WELL
GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FREDDIE RODRIGUEZ AND THE
HELLO. MY NAME WITH THEIR
ALLOWS THE FARCICAL BOSTON IS
COMING FOR AN APARTMENT. AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY. AND ALSO- SHARE MY
THOUGHTS- IN RELATION TO THE-
MAKE AVAILABLE IN ADDITION TO
THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS BOB FIRST OF ALL IF
YOU KNOW WHAT KIND OF ALL
SANDERS IS THE LARGEST COUNTY
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH
OVER TEN MILLION PEOPLE. FROM
THE FIRE DEPARTMENT'S
PERSPECTIVE ON WHERE AN ALL
RISK ORGANIZATION ALONG- WE ARE
INVOLVED IN OGDENSBURG DISEASE
EXCEPT I SOMETIMES SAY SUPPOSED
TO REQUIRE REQUIRE CONST LOS
LAW ENFORCEMENT SO EARLY ON-
BLOSSOMS COMING APART APARTMENT
PARTNERED. WITH THE- PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE HEALTH HERE
LAWSUIT CAN- WE GAVE AND ME.
MISTER MANAGEMENT TEAM TO HELP
WITH THE INITIALLOGISTICS OF
THE PANDEMIC ABOUT OPERATION
ROOM KEY. DETAILS ABOUT OUR
SERVICES. ARE NEEDED THE FIRST
THIRTY. TEST SITES BECOME
BOSTON. AND HAD LATER COLLAPSE
WITH- PUBLIC HEALTH TWO SEVEN
PARTS IN BLIGHTED SET UP FIVE.
OF THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES IN
LA CITY HAVE THEIR MAJOR PART
OF LOT OF A GARCIA WHO ANOTHER
PARTS OF THE FOREST SERVICE.
MCCARTY AND THIS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE CALIFORNIA- MEDICARE-
COLLABORATION SUPPORT AS IT
RELATES TO. A PUBLIC HEALTH
AGENCIES AND COVERED BY TAKING.
OUT I KNOW THAT. I WERE TRYING
TO TRANSITION OUT OF THE-
THAT'S NATION PROCESS I BELIEVE
CARRY FIRE BECAUSE WE'RE
GETTING A FOR A WHILE AND FOR
SEASON AND BECAME THE LIFE
GUARDS. IT'S A STEP IN THE BUT
THAT'S MY AND OF IT THE PART
ONLY PARTNER. WITH OUR HEALTH
APART IN HEALTH AGENCIES WE
GAVE ONE MILLION OF HERE. LOS
ANGELES CA TO. OUR CITIES. AS
YOU KNOW IS A NORMAL- MY
ORGANIZATION WE ALWAYS TRY TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
INITIATIVES. ABOUT WE TRY TO
PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES TO OUR
NEEDIEST COMMUNITIES IN THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES. BECAUSE
TYPICALLY THOSE ARE BUSIEST
COMMUNITIES AS IT RELATES TO
OUR EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
MISSION OUR PARAMEDICS SO THE
SAME THING A CURRENT WHEN WE
PARTNER WITH OUR PUBLIC. HEALTH
AGENCY THAT WE ASSURED ME THAT-
WE PUT PARTS IN SOME OF OUR
NEEDIEST COMMUNITIES TO ENSURE
THAT- THOSE. OPPORTUNITIES GOT
THE SERVICES THEY NEED IT FROM
SUPPLIES TO. ALL TESTING INTO
LATER VACCINE I WORKED WORKED
VERY CLOSELY WITH. ALL THE
LAWSUIT IS COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND ALSO MY
COUNTERPART OF BARBER FOR RARE
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH WITHIN. OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH TEAM I THINK THAT
WE OVERALL DID WELL AS THE
INCIDENT AND I'LL I WILL
CONCLUDE MY COMMENTS. SAVE SOME
OF. THE QUESTIONS THAT OTHER
PEOPLE SPEAK. BUT AS ANY-
INSTEAD OF HAD A THE CAREER AND
I AND IT IS PREVENT FOR ALMOST
FORTY YEARS. I'M THERE'S ALWAYS
LESSONS IN TO WOULD BE FINE AND
I THINK. WALKING FROM
ACCOUNTING EXPERTS WITH COUNTY
AGENTS. AS WE HAD STONE WE WERE
TO. RESOLVE THOSE TALENTS AND
EXPERTISE MANNER- YEAH BEEN
SOME INSTANCES THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE T. THE EX OF FOR
THE STATE. BUT I THINK THAT IN
SOME INSTANCES FROM- YES OF M.
SORT OF PUBLIC HEALTH I WE
COULD COLLABORATE A LITTLE BIT
BETTER- EDUCATION TO
COMMUNICATIONS BOB AS WE
SOMETIMES SAY IT'S AN EMERGENCY
INCIDENTS THAT ALL PARTIES ARE
LOCAL AND THEN HE SPED OUT TO
THE STATE AND FEDERAL AGENCIES
FOR ASSISTANCE AND I THINK
THEY'RE IN SOME AREAS ALTHOUGH
A VERY. OBJECTIVE WAS WORLD
INTENDED BECAUSE DONE WELL AS
FAR AS COORDINATION- OVERALL
PROJECT WAS TO GET SHOTS OF
PEOPLE'S ARMS AND WE WERE ABLE
TO DO THAT THE LAST THING I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY- TO THE CONDO-
IS. I MEAN WE IS FOR. AND FROM
MY BUDGET THE SOLAR CHOSEN SURE
EVERYONE BELT BUT IT'S A
CHALLENGE. IT'S ALWAYS A
CHALLENGE GET. OF RAMPARTS BUT
SINCE I KNEW THAT LIVES WERE AT
STAKE- I PUT THAT ON THE BACK
BURNER BUT WE'RE STILL TRYING
TO GO THROUGH THE PROCESSES OF
GETTING REAL. BURST OUT
THROUGH. OF FAME- OR THE COUNTY
OR THE STATE AS IT RELATES TO
SOME OF OUR OWN COMMITMENTS ONE
THING THAT I WOULD LIKE TO SAY
BEFORE I. AM THIS IS THERE I WE
WORK VERY WELL WITH CAL POLY
HAS. AS IT RELATES TO PRE
POSITIONING FUNDING- THE
GOVERNOR SEVERAL YEARS AGO. UP
AWARDED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. OR FOR FUNDING
INITIALLY FOR OUR WELLNESS
SAID. BUT REALLY THAT. FUNDING
IS FOR- ALL RISK FACTOR. IN SO
WE'VE USED FUNDING. A WALL FIRE
HIM AN FLOODS. ARE WE ALWAYS
KNEW THAT IT CAN MAKING A
CURRENT BUT- WE WERE ON A TO
USE THE FUND FOR. AND I THINK
THAT OF THE LESSON LEARNED WITH
THAT THEY ABOUT. YOU KNOW TO
HELP MORE DIAL TO TALK ABOUT
LEARNED IT. WHAT WE DO WELCOME
CAN DO TO IMPROVE. AND ALSO TO.
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OF
THE STATE ALLOCATES TO ALWAYS
ASK FOR PRE POSITIONING. FOR
ALL FROM ALL RISK IS THIS
REALLY. A DROP IN THE BUCKET.
YEAH I THAT. AWFULLY THIS CALL.
OTHERS THAT WE CAN DO A LOT
BETTER JOB IN RELATION TO THE-
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
TO ALL WE ASK FOR A STATE
MISSIONS. ARE WE LOOK AT THE
CHILE FROM A FARMER'S
PERSPECTIVE- OVER 56% ALMOST
SIX PERCENT. OF RESOURCES FOR
MUTUAL EIGHT. COME FROM LOCAL
RESOURCES PROCESS ABOUT THE
STATE AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WITH THEIR- RESPONSES AND I
THINK THAT. THERE'S NO NUMBERS
THERE'S NO DATA YET. IN
RELATION TO THE COMMITMENT.
THAT WAS GIVEN BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. A FOR THESE
MISSIONS I THINK THAT. HELLO IS
ONE OF THE ACCOMPLICE BEGIN
ADDITIONAL FIVE. OF THE WITHIN
THE MICRO RIGHT NOW IT WILL
HAVE WITHIN. GIVEN HOW LONG I
COULD. THAT'S WHAT I WOULD TELL
ME THAT B. O. THEY BROKE OTHERS
SPEAKERS AT FOLLOW. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I'M VERY MUCH OF ALL
OF THE- NEXT WILL HAVE. A ME
SESSION HOPEFULLY PROFESSOR
FROM THE ALL PARMER THE PUBLIC.
CARE WHEN YOU'RE A ANY. YEAH
COULD COULD MORE CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES HEAR. OKAY WELL THANK
YOU FOR THE UP TO PROVIDE THE
PERSPECTIVE OF A SMALL LOCAL
APARTMENT REGARDING THE ROLL
OUT OF CODE NINETEEN VACCINES
AND OTHERS HEALTH OFFICER FOR
YOLO COUNTY I'VE GUIDED OUR
COUNTIES COVERT NINETEEN
pVACCINE ROLLOUT. WE'VE COME A
LONG WAY SINCE I FIRST
TESTIFIED BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
IN EARLY FEBRUARY I AM PLEASED
TO REPORT. THAT OUT OF SUNDAY
48% OF ALL YOLO COUNTY
RESIDENTS HAVE RECEIVED AT
LEAST ONE DOSE OF VACCINE AND
33% OF YOUR COUNTY RESIDENTS
ARE FULLY VACCINATED. A TOTAL
OF ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOSES HAVE BEEN
ADMINISTERED IN OUR COUNTY OF
TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE. YOUR COUNTIES
HELP DEPARTMENT IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH OUR OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES AS ADMINISTERED OVER
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND DOSES. WELL
THE COUNTY ITSELF HAS GIVEN
MORE DOSES TO COUNTY RESIDENTS
THAN ANY OTHER VACCINE PROVIDER
WE WOULD NOT HAVE GOTTEN 2408%
OF RESIDENTS WHO RECEIVED AT
LEAST ONE DOSE WITHOUT THE
INVOLVEMENT OF MANY PROVIDERS
INCLUDING CHAIN PHARMACIES
FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTERS. LARGE HEALTH SYSTEMS
FIRE DEPARTMENT AND EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES PERSONNEL UC
DAVIS AND A CITY UNIVERSITY
PARTNERSHIP KNOWN AS THE DAVIS
TOGETHER. TO DATE YOUR COUNTY
PUBLIC HEALTH APPROACH TO
VACCINATION HAS BEEN A HYBRID
OF MASS VACCINATION A DRIVE
THROUGH CLINICS AND MORE
FOCUSED MOBILE OUTREACH.
HOWEVER EVEN OUR MASTER
ACTIVATION SITES OR MOBILE
THESE CLINICS ROTATE FOR
SEVERAL LOCATIONS IN THE COUNTY
TO PROVIDE GEOGRAPHIC SPREAD
PRIMARILY IN OUR THREE LARGEST
CITIES OF WOODLAND WEST
SACRAMENTO AND DAVIS. MATHIS
VACCINATION IN A SMALL COUNTY
LIKE YOLO MEANS SOMETHING
DIFFERENT THAN L. A. COUNTY WE
CONSIDER ANYTHING WITH THREE
HUNDRED OR MORE DOSES PER DAY
TO BE A MASS VACCINATION CLINIC.
INITIALLY WE USED EVENTBRITE
PUBLIC LINKS FOR SIGN UPS THAT
MASS VACCINATION SITES BUT WE
MIGRATED TO THE MY TURN
PLATFORM RECENTLY AS REQUIRED
BY THE THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR FOR ITS NEW TP A
NETWORK ONCE THE SYSTEM HAD THE
FUNCTIONALITY WE NEEDED. WE
RECOGNIZED EARLY ON THAT WE
NEEDED ADDITIONAL EFFORTS TO
REACH DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND HARDER TO REACH
POPULATIONS. WE WORK WITH
COMMUNITY PARTNERS TO IDENTIFY
THOSE WHO WOULD NEED SUCH NEED
MORE SUPPORT AND THEN SATISFIED
DOSES FOR MEMBERS OF THESE
GROUPS AT MATH VACCINATION
CLINICS USING PRIVATE
EVENTBRITE LINKS. PHONE NUMBERS
WERE PROVIDED TO SUPPORT THOSE
WITHOUT INTERNET ACCESS OR
LIMITED DIGITAL LITERACY. WE
OFFER DEDICATED VACCINE EVENTS
FOR CERTAIN GROUPS USUALLY OUT
OF FAMILIAR SIGHT AND SOMETIMES
WITH INCENTIVES. FOR EXAMPLE
ONE CLINIC FOR CHILDCARE
WORKERS WAS ADVERTISED BY FIRST
FIVE HELD AT THE COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION AND OFFERED FREE
DIAPERS AND OTHER GIVEAWAYS. WE
ALSO PARTNERED WITH TWO ONE ONE
TO SIGN UP THOSE WHO NEEDED A
VACCINE IN THEIR HOME AND
WORKED WITH AMERICAN MEDICAL
RESPONSE AND FIRE DEPARTMENTS
TO PROVIDE THESE IN HOME
VACCINATIONS. HELLO COUNTY HAS
A SUBSTANTIAL FARMWORKER
POPULATION WHO ARE PRIMARILY
LATINO. WE SURVEYED FARM
BUSINESSES REGARDING HOW MANY
EMPLOYEES WANTED VACCINES AND
THEN SCHEDULED THESE EMPLOYEES
INTO VACCINE CLINICS HELD ON
THE FARMS THEMSELVES. THANKS TO
THESE EFFORTS WE ESTIMATE THAT
83% OF FARMWORKERS AND YOLO
COUNTY HAVE RECEIVED AT LEAST
ONE DOSE OF VACCINE. YET
DESPITE THESE CONCERTED EFFORTS
TOWARDS BACKING UP WITH THE
VACCINE IN EQUITY IS PERSISTENT
YOLO COUNTY. NEARLY ANY WAY YOU
SLICE THE DATA CERTAIN GROUPS
HAVE A HIGHER PROPORTION OF
VACCINATED PERSONS THAN OTHERS.
THE DISPARITIES ARE
PARTICULARLY VISIBLE BY
ETHNICITY AND BY ZIP CODE. YOLO
COUNTY'S MOST DISADVANTAGED
APPROACH I'VE MEASURED BY THE
HEALTHY PLACES INDEX IS NINE
FIVE SIX OH FIVE IN WEST
SACRAMENTO. COMPARED TO THE
COUNTY AVERAGE OF 48% OF
RESIDENTS AT LEAST PARTIALLY
VACCINATED ONLY 29% OF
RESIDENTS AND NINE FIVE SIX OH
FIVE HAVE BEEN VACCINATED.
BECAUSE OF THIS GAP ARE
MULTIFACTORIAL AND INCLUDE
TRANSPORTATION BARRIERS
LANGUAGE BARRIERS IN SPANISH
AND RUSSIAN SPEAKING
POPULATIONS AND BAXEEN
HESITANCY AMONG CERTAIN GROUPS.
WE HAVE RESPONDED FOR THE
DISPARITIES BY HOLDING VACCINE
CLINICS IN NINE FIVE SIX OH
FIVE DEDICATED TO PEOPLE WHO
LIVE AND WORK AND THE ZIP CODE.
WE PARTNER WITH MULTIPLE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
TO SIGN UP INTERESTED
INDIVIDUALS AND TO PROVIDE
LANGUAGE SERVICES AT THE
CLINICS. JUST OUTSIDE OF NINE
pVACCINATION SITE IS OPEN FOR
THOSE WITH APPOINTMENTS AND FOR
WALK INS. FREE TRANSPORTATION
IS AVAILABLE TO THE SITE. FOR
NOW EXPLORING INCENTIVES TO
ENCOURAGE VACCINATION. ONE
LESSON LEARNED FROM OUR EFFORTS
IN WEST SACRAMENTO IS THAT WE
ARE NOT BUILDING A FIELD OF
DREAMS IT'S NOT AS SIMPLE AS IF
YOU BUILD IT A. K. A. VACCINE.
THEY WILL COME. ACCESS TO
VACCINE IS JUST ONE PIECE OF A
COMPLEX PUZZLE. AN ADDITIONAL
FORM OF VACCINE IN EQUITY IN
YOLO COUNTY IS UNDER
VACCINATION OF LATINOS.
MARTINO'S COMPRISE 32% OF
PEOPLE COUNTY RESIDENTS BUT
ONLY 18% OF YOUR COUNTY
RESIDENTS VACCINATED TO DATE.
THIS DISPARITY IS DUE AT LEAST
IN PART TO POOR DATA. ACCORDING
TO THE STATE'S BAXEEN DASHBOARD
NEARLY 15% OF THOSE VACCINATED
AND YOU'LL COUNTY TODAY ARE OF
UNKNOWN ETHNICITY. IN SOME
CASES YOUR COUNTY ACTUALLY
HOUSE A NECESSITY DATA ON THESE
UNKNOWN PERSONS BUT HASN'T BEEN
ABLE TO GET THE STATE'S
IMMUNIZATION REGISTRY UPDATED.
USING YOLO IS IMPROVED DATA
ONLY 6% OF THOSE VACCINATED ARE
MISTING ETHNICITY COMPARED TO
THE 15% REPORTED AS UNKNOWN BY
THE STATE. INCREASING THE
PROPORTION OF LATINO VACCINIA
IS FROM 18% TO TWENTY ONE
PERCENT. WHILE IMPROVED WE
STILL FALL SHORT OF THE 32%
LATINO POPULATION PROPORTION.
YOUR COUNTY IS NOW FUNDING
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AS TRUSTED MESSENGERS TO
ENCOURAGE VACCINATION AMONG
LATINOS. WE ARE ALSO WORKING TO
MAKE VACCINES MORE CONVENIENT
RECOGNIZING THAT SOME PEOPLE
MAY NOT GO OUT OF THEIR WAY TO
BE VACCINATED BUT THEY WON'T
TURN DOWN A VACCINE THAT LANDS
IN THEIR LAPS. IN THE COMING
WEEKS WILL BE OFFERING VACCINE
AT CATHOLIC CHURCHES LATINO
GROCERY STORES. OF WORKPLACES
AND SCHOOLS AS WELL AS AFTER
WORK AND ON WEEKENDS. I REMAIN
CRITICAL OF STATE LEVEL
APPROACHES TO IMPROVE TIMELY
ACCESS TO VACCINES PARTICULARLY
MY TURN AT THE T. PA NETWORK.
BOTH WERE WELL INTENTIONED BUT
THEY ARRIVED ON THE SCENE TOO
LATE TO SOLVE FOR WHICH THEY
WERE CREATED. THIS ISN'T
NECESSARILY ANYONE'S FAULT. IT
SIMPLY DIFFICULT FOR LARGE
ENTITIES TO PIVOT AS SITUATIONS
CHANGE WHEREAS SMALLER ENTITIES
CAN BE MORE NIMBLE. FOR EXAMPLE
BY THE TIME MY TURN WAS
TECHNICALLY ABLE TO LIMIT
REGISTRATIONS BY COUNTY OF
RESIDENCE AND STATE POLICY
ENABLED SUCH GEO FENCING IN
ORDER TO RESTRICT VACCINE FOR
ISLAM MANY COUNTIES USING MY
TURN HAD SEEN A DECREASE AND
DEMANDS. THEY ENDED UP USING
THE GEO FENCING FEATURE FOR
ONLY A SHORT TIME BEFORE
OPENING VACCINES TO ALL. THE
VACCINE SITUATION IN CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES CHANGES QUICKLY AND
LARGE STATEWIDE SYSTEMS JUST
CAN'T KEEP UP AS WE MOVE FROM
VACCINE SCARCITY TO VACCINE
HESITANCY WITHIN JUST A FEW
WEEKS FIVE. THIS IS ALSO TRUE
OF THE TP A NETWORK DEVELOPED
TO IMPROVE VACCINE EFFICIENCY
AND EXPAND VACCINATION CAPACITY
IN CALIFORNIA. HOWEVER THE TP A
NETWORK HAS DONE LITTLE TO
EXPAND YOLO COUNTY VACCINATION
CAPACITY IN ROLLING FEW NEW
PROVIDERS AND HAS CERTAINLY NOT
IMPROVED EFFICIENCY. I NOW
SPEND SEVERAL HOURS EACH WEEK
COMPLETING SPREADSHEETS AND IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH BLUE SHIELD
REPRESENTATIVES TO REVIEW
PROPOSED VACCINE ALLOCATIONS
ONLY IN MANY CASES TO FIND THAT
THE TPPA DID NOT ALLOCATE THOSE
THOSE TO PROVIDERS AS
RECOMMENDED. AS THE FDA LOOKS
TO AUTHORIZE THE FIVES OF
VACCINE FOR ADOLESCENTS TWELVE
TO FIFTEEN YEARS OLD I STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE MOVING AWAY FROM THE
TVA NETWORK AND TOWARD AN
EXISTING NETWORK OF PROVIDERS.
KNOWN AS VACCINES FOR CHILDREN
OR VFC PROVIDERS. COMPRISED OF
PEDIATRIC AND FAMILY MEDICINE
PHYSICIAN OFFICES VFC PROVIDERS
ARE A TRUSTED SOURCE OF
INFORMATION VACCINES AND
INFORMATION ABOUT VACCINES.
RATHER THAN PUSHING ALL THESE
EXISTING VFC PROVIDERS ON TO
THE NEW TP A NETWORK I
ENCOURAGE USE OF THE EXISTING
VFC ABOUT WORK AND ADDITIONAL
PEDIATRIC PROVIDERS TO
VACCINATE YOUNGER CALIFORNIANS
IN THE NEXT PHASE OF THE
VACCINE ROLLOUT. PSC PROVIDERS
ARE ALREADY PARTNERED WITH
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS TO
DELIVER OTHER VACCINES. LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS HAVE THE
ABILITY TO ACCEPT BORDER FIZER
SHIPMENTS AND TRANSFER SMALLER
NUMBER OF DOSES TO INDIVIDUAL
PROVIDERS KING OF THE STORE OR
USE THE LARGE MINIMUM SHIPMENTS
AVAILABLE FROM FIZER FIFTY P.
EIGHT DOES NOT HAVE THIS
ABILITY. WITH ALL THE FOCUS ON
VACCINATION TESTING FOR COVERT
NINETEEN HAS FALLEN OFF THE
RADAR OF SOMEBODY. YET IT
REMAINS A CRITICAL STRATEGY IN
CONTROLLING SPREAD OF COVERT
NINETEEN. BECAUSE 40% OF COVERT
NINETEEN CASES HAVE NO SYMPTOMS
THE ONLY WAY TO KNOW SOMEONE
DOES NOT HAVE CONVEYED THIS TO
TEST THEM FOR KOBE. ONCE
VACCINATED THE NEED FOR TESTING
THOSE WITHOUT SYMPTOMS GOES
AWAY. BUT CENTS LESS THAN HALF
OF CALIFORNIANS ARE FULLY
VACCINATED MORE THAN HALF OF
CALIFORNIANS WOULD STILL
BENEFIT FROM REGULAR COBIT
TESTING. EXISTING TESTING SITES
ARE UNDER UTILIZED ACROSS
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING IN YOLO
COUNTY DESPITE TEST BEING FREE
AND RESULTS BEING PROVIDED
FASTER THAN EVER TYPICALLY ONE
DAY AFTER TESTING. SOME TESTING
PROVIDERS IN YOLO COUNTY ARE
EXPLORING INCENTIVES FOR
TESTING INCLUDING A RECENT
TESTING EVENT AT A MIGRANT
HOUSING CENTER THAT OFFERED
FREE TACOS FOR PARTICIPANTS. IN
SUMMARY YOUR COUNTY HAS MADE
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS IN
VACCINATING NEARLY HALF OF ITS
RESIDENTS WITH AT LEAST ONE
DOSE OF VACCINE. HOWEVER THAT'S
PROGRESS HAS NOT REACHED ALL
RESIDENTS EQUALLY WITH LATINOS
AND CERTAIN ZIP CODES BEING
LEFT BEHIND. CONCERTED EFFORTS
ARE BEING MADE TO IMPROVE
VACCINATION RATES IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES BUT
THE WORK IS HARD AND PROGRESS
SLOW. DESPITE THIS CHALLENGE WE
WILL CONTINUE TO DO THIS WORK
BECAUSE IT IS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO BECAUSE IT IS NECESSARY
TO STOP THE SPREAD OF THIS
DEADLY VIRUS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION THIS
MORNING. THANK YOU AMY NOW WILL
LOOK TO HEAR FROM DR PAUL SIMON
FROM LOS SOUNDS COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
THANK YOU ARE COMMITTEE CHAIR
ROD REGUS AND HONORABLE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR INVITING
ME AGAIN TO SPEAK WITH YOU
ABOUT L. A. COUNTY SCOPE AT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES. INCLUDING THE
VITALLY IMPORTANT PARTNERSHIPS
THAT HAVE BEEN ESTABLISHED
BETWEEN THE L. A. COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
LOCAL AND STATE EMERGENCY
RESPONSE AGENCIES IN SUPPORTING
THESE ACTIVITIES. AS IS TRUE
ACROSS THE STATE- WE'VE SEEN
DRAMATIC REDUCTIONS IN COVERT
NINETEEN CASES HOSPITALIZATIONS
AND DEATHS IN L. A. COUNTY IN
RECENT WEEKS. OPENS FOR FLOOD
THE NUMBER OF FACTORS BUT OF
CENTRAL IMPORTANCE HAS BEEN THE
CONTINUED COOPERATION AND
COORDINATION BETWEEN LOCAL AND
STATE AGENCIES AND OTHER
PARTNERS INCLUDING OUR
PARTNERSHIPS WITH LOCAL FIRE
DEPARTMENTS AND OTHER FIRST
RESPONDERS. AND OTHER COUNTY
DEPARTMENTS AS WELL AS OUR
STATE COUNTERPARTS. L. A.
COUNTY HAS A VAST VACCINE
DISTRICT DISTRIBUTION NETWORK
WHICH CURRENTLY INCLUDES OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED VACCINATION SITES
DISPERSED ACROSS THE COUNTY.
THIS NETWORK IS SUPPORTED BY
PARTNERSHIPS WITH HOSPITALS
FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTERS. OTHER COMMUNITY
CLINICS PHARMACIES AND PRIVATE
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS. PART OF
THE NETWORK BUT COUNTY IT'S
ALSO BEEN OPERATING BETWEEN
SEVEN AND EIGHT MASS
VACCINATION SITES SINCE MID
JANUARY WITH THE CAPACITY TO
VACCINATE 1-800-022-0000 PEOPLE
A DAY. I AS CHIEF OSBY
MENTIONED- IN TOTAL OVER ONE
MILLION VACCINATIONS HAVE BEEN
ADMINISTERED AT THE SITES OVER
THE PAST THREE AND A HALF
MONTHS. FOR THESE COUNTY RUN
MASS VACCINATION SITES PUBLIC
HEALTH SHARES UNIFIED COMMAND
WOOD COUNTY FIRE AND OUR OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT IN AN
INCIDENT COMMAND STRUCTURE.
THROUGHOUT THE PARTNERSHIP WITH
FIRE AND- EM WE HAVE USED A
SHARED MANAGEMENT APPROACH.
PUBLIC HEALTH IS MAINTAINED THE
OVERALL SITE LEADERSHIP OF
THESE COUNTY VACCINATION SITES
INCLUDING FINANCING FISCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY AND COST
MANAGEMENT STAFF RECRUITMENT
AND SUPERVISION CLINICAL
PROTOCOLS AND PROCEDURES BAXEEN
MANAGEMENT APPOINTMENT
SCHEDULING AND REGISTRATION.
BAXEEN RELATED DATA COLLECTION
REPORTING AND BAXEEN MESSAGING
AND COMMUNICATIONS. HOW THE
FIRE HAS BEEN ESSENTIAL PART
BEEN A SUPPLIED PHYSICAL SITE
MANAGEMENT AND OVERSIGHT. AS
POSSIBLY MENTIONED LOGISTICAL
SUPPORT AT EACH OF THESE SITES
A QUICK MINTON'S REPLY
ORGANIZATION REPLENISHMENT
TRAFFIC CONTROL ONSITE FIRE AND
AMBULANCE SERVICES CRISIS
RESPONSE PLANNING
IMPLEMENTATION AND HAS SERVED
AS LIAISON WITH OFF SITE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
STAKEHOLDERS COUNTY OEM HAS
BEEN RESPONSIBLE FOR OVERALL
MISSION MANAGEMENT AND
ORGANIZATION INCLUDING SITE
SELECTION LIAISON WITH VENUE
MANAGEMENT AND OVERSIGHT OF
CONTRACTUAL OBLIGATIONS.
MOBILIZING BACKS- A MASS
VACCINATION SITES HAS BEEN AN
IMMENSE EFFORT THAT IS REQUIRED
EXTENSIVE RESOURCES TIME AND
COORDINATION. THESE SITES HAVE
PLAYED AN INTEGRAL ROLE IN
GETTING VACCINE OUT QUICKLY
WELL BEING SUPPLEMENTED BY MANY
OTHER STRATEGIES TO GET VACCINE
INTO THE ARMS OF RESIDENTS.
WELL VERY EFFECTIVE IN GETTING
A LARGE NUMBER OF VACCINATIONS
ADMINISTERED EARLY ON WHEN
DEMAND FOR VACCINE WAS VERY
HIGH. THESE LARGE COUNTY
VACCINE SITES WERE LESS
EFFECTIVE IN REACHING RESIDENTS
IN THE HARDEST HIT COMMUNITIES.
TRANSPORTATION OTHER ACCESS
BARRIERS AT THE SITES. MAY HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO SOME OF THE
EARLY INEQUITIES IN VACCINATION
RATES IN THE COUNTY THE
SUBSTITUTING ADDITIONAL EFFORTS
TO TARGET TARGET THE HARDEST
HIT COMMUNITIES THROUGH
NEIGHBORHOOD SPECIFIC CLINICS
AND OTHER FOCUSED APPROACHES.
PUBLIC HEALTH IS ALSO
PARTNERING WITH FIRST
RESPONDERS IN OUR WORK WITH
MUNICIPAL FIRE DEPARTMENTS
ACROSS L. A. COUNTY AS PART OF
OUR MULTI PRONGED STRATEGY TO
VACCINATE HOMEBOUND RESIDENTS.
SPECIFICALLY WERE WORKING WITH
MUNICIPAL FIRE DEPARTMENTS TO
VOLUNTARILY BACKS THE WHOLE BY
RESIDENTS IN CITIES
JURISDICTIONS. AND USING
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES TO
IDENTIFY HOME BOUND RESIDENTS
INCLUDING CLIENT. REFERRALS
FROM COMMUNITY PARTNERS CITIES
AND REGIONAL CENTERS PROVIDING
SERVICES TO HOMEBOUND RESIDENTS.
INDIVISIBLE FIRE DEPARTMENTS
ARE ALSO GIVEN THE OPTION TO
VACCINATE HOMEBOUND INDIVIDUALS
IDENTIFIED BY THEIR TEAM WHILE
FOLLOWING RECOMMENDED HOMEBOUND
CRITERIA PROVIDED BY PUBLIC
HEALTH. PUBLIC HEALTH IS ALSO
ALLOCATING VACCINES TO SUPPORT
THE EFFORTS OF THE L. A. COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT TO REACH
HOME BOUND INDIVIDUALS THE
MAJORITY OF WHOM ARE ADULTS
WITH DISABILITIES UNDER THE AGE
OF SIXTY FOUR. THANKS TO THESE
MANY PARTNERSHIPS AND OTHER
IMPORTANT STRATEGIES TO DATE WE
HAVE ADMINISTERED MORE THAN
EIGHT MILLION TOTAL DOSES OF
VACCINE L. A. COUNTY. WITH
ABOUT FIVE MILLION FIRST DOSES
AND THREE MILLION SECOND DOSES.
UNFORTUNATELY JUSTICE IN YOLO
COUNTY WE CONTINUE TO SEE LARGE
DISPARITIES IN VACCINATION
RATES ACROSS THE COUNTY. FOR
EXAMPLE IN SOME OF OUR MOST
AFFLUENT CITIES AND
COMMUNITIES. MORE THAN 60% OF
THOSE SIXTEEN AND OLDER
RECEIVED AT LEAST ONE DOSE OF
VACCINE. WELL IN SOME OF OUR
LEAST AFFLUENT CITIES LESS THAN
40% OF RECEIVED ONE OR MORE
DOSES. SIMILARLY WE CONTINUE TO
SEE LARGE DISPARITIES IN
VACCINATION RATES BY RACE AND
ETHNICITY WITH THE HIGHEST
RATES AMONG WHITES AND ASIANS
AND THE LOWEST RATES AMONG
LATINOS AND AFRICAN AMERICANS.
WE ALSO SEE HIGHER VACCINATION
RATES AMONG WOMEN THAN MEN. WE
HAVE SEEN SOME PROGRESS IN
REDUCING THESE INEQUITIES FOR
EXAMPLE OVER THE PAST TWO
MONTHS THE PERCENTAGE OF THOSE
SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER. WHO HAVE
RECEIVED AT LEAST ONE DOSE OF
VACCINE INCREASED MORE RAPIDLY
AMONG BLACK LATINO AND AMERICAN
INDIAN AND ALASKA NATIVE
RESIDENTS THAN AMONG WHITES AND
ASIANS. HOWEVER MUCH MORE WORK
NEEDS TO BE DONE TO CLOSE THESE
UNACCEPTABLE GAPS. WE REMAIN
COMMITTED TO INCREASING THE
VACCINE DOSES ALLOCATED TO THE
HARDEST HIT ZIP CODES IN L. A.
COUNTY. FOR EXAMPLE OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL MONTHS WE HAVE
STEADILY INCREASED THE
ALLOCATION OF VACCINE DOSES. TO
OUR NETWORK PROVIDERS LOCATED
IN THE HARDEST HIT COMMUNITIES
WITH NEARLY 75% OF THOSE IS NOW
GOING TO THESE PROVIDERS. IN
ADDITION TO ALLOATING CLOSEST
TO PROVIDERS IN THESE
COMMUNITIES MOBILE OF ACCIDENT
VACCINATION TEAMS ARE
INCREASINGLY BEING DEPLOYED. TO
THESE HIGH NEED AREAS FOR
EXAMPLE OVER THE NEXT TWO WEEKS
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TEMPORARY VACCINATION
SITES WILL BE ESTABLISHED. BY
THESE TEAMS THAT SENIOR HOUSING
SITES SENIOR CENTERS HOUSES OF
WORSHIP AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS IN THESE AREAS.
CAN I SIT REACHING THE
REMAINING POPULATION THAT HAS
NOT YET BEEN VACCINATED WILL
BECOME INCREASINGLY CHALLENGING
GIVEN THE RELUCTANCE OF MANY TO
BE VACCINATED. THEREFORE WE
LOOK TO IMPLEMENT TARGETED
STRATEGIES TO CONTINUE
IMPROVING OUR OVERALL UP ACTION
AND APPROXIMATION RATES WITH
THESE GROUPS INCLUDING
PROVIDING ACCURATE INFORMATION
TO HELP PEOPLE MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS. PARTNERING WITH
NONPROFITS AND FAITH BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO SERVICE
VACCINATION SITES AND TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR MAKING
APPOINTMENTS IN PROVIDING
PATIENT EDUCATION. OFFERING
DIFFERENT POINTS OF VACCINE
ACCESS INCLUDING CLOSED VACCINE
DISPENSING SITES FOR THE
HARDEST HIT COMMUNITIES AND FOR
ELIGIBLE ESSENTIAL WORKERS
MOBILE VACCINATION CLINICS.
OFFERING WALK UP SITES AND
ADDITIONAL SERVICES WITHOUT
APPOINTMENTS NEEDED FOR OLDER
ADULTS PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES AND THOSE WHO ARE
HOME BOUND AS WELL AS- OTHER.
RESIDENTS HAVE BEEN HARD HIT
COMMUNITIES. THE PRECIPITOUS
DECLINE IN VACCINATION DEMAND
IN RECENT DAYS HAS ALL HAS ALSO
IMPACTED THE COUNTY PARK
OPERATIONS AS THEY STRUGGLE TO
PLAN FOR STAFFING. NEEDED
VACCINE SUPPLIES FOOTPRINT
REDUCTIONS AND OTHER
OPERATIONAL ACTIVITIES
DECREASED DEMAND HAS REQUIRED
US TO IMPLEMENT. NO APPOINTMENT
NEEDED APPROACH AS MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY WHICH MAKES SITE
STAFF AND RESOURCE PLANNING
MUCH MORE CHALLENGING. I WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE WITH A FEW
RECOMMENDATIONS FIRST THE
STATE'S SUPPORT OF A MEDICAL
HEALTH OPERATIONAL AREA
COORDINATION PROGRAM AND SUPPLY
OF CLINICAL AND NONCLINICAL
STAFFING FOR THE BEST
VACCINATION SITES HAS BEEN
CRITICAL TO THE SUCCESS OF THIS
MISSION AND WE ENCOURAGE
CONTINUED SUPPORT IN THIS AREA.
THE STATE'S VACCINE APPOINTMENT
AND REGISTRATIONS CORRECT
REGISTRATION SYSTEM. ARE HAS
DOCTORS THIS MANSION HAS
REMAINED A CHALLENGE LOCAL
STAFF OF HAD TO DEVELOP
NUMEROUS WORKAROUNDS TO
OVERCOME DATA SYSTEM A LIST OF
THE MEDICATIONS. WHICH ARE
DRAMATICALLY AFFECTED
OPERATIONAL ACTIVITIES IN THE
COUNTY. HOWEVER WE DO
APPRECIATE THE STATE'S EFFORTS
IN WORKING TO IMPROVE THE
SYSTEM. AND THAT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED
ENHANCEMENTS OF THE SYSTEM. WE
ALSO MUCH APPRECIATE INCREASED
WE WILL ALSO MUCH APPRECIATE
INCREASED COORDINATION WITH
CAL- E. S. AND FEDERAL PARTNERS
UNDER VACCINATION EFFORTS IN
OUR JURISDICTION. AS UP- AS-
RECTOR HOUSE BE MENTIONED- WE
BELIEVE THAT- WELL WE WERE
READY PROJECT THE OP THE
EFFORTS OF THE STATE FEDERAL
AGENCIES IN THE COUNTY AND
SUPPORTING OUR VACCINATION
EFFORTS WE DO FEEL THAT WE ARE
COULD HAVE BEEN THAT COULD BE
IN THE FUTURE MORE EFFICIENT
AND PRODUCTIVE WITH INCREASED
COORDINATION. ON CBO'S AND
FAITH BASED A PARTNER SENIOR
CENTER IS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SITES AND OTHER COMMUNITY
PARTNERS HAVE BEEN INSTRUMENTAL
IN REACHING HARD HIT
POPULATIONS FUNDING FOR THESE
PARK- PARTNERS EVEN SMALL
STIPEND AMOUNTS WOULD ASSIST IN
HAVING BROADER REACH FOR
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
INVESTING STAFF. TIME FOR
INVESTING STAFF TIME SPACE OUR
REGION OTHER RESOURCES TO
MOBILIZE THEIR CONSTITUENCIES
TO CONTACTS NATION SITES TO
ASSIST OUR LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT RESIDENTS WE WOULD
WELCOME SUPPORT FOR LANGUAGE
ACCESS WHICH CREDIT WHICH IS
CRITICAL. FOR MOBILE
VACCINATION EFFORTS. FIVE I
WOULD LIKE TO EMPHASIZE THAT
WILL HELP A. COUNTY IN THE
STATE ARE CURRENTLY IN A
RELATIVELY GOOD PLACE WITH
REGARD TO THE PANDEMIC
VACCINATION EFFORTS WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT WE REMAIN
VULNERABLE. WE KNOW THAT CASE
NUMBERS ARE RISING IN SOME OF
OUR NEIGHBORING STATES. AND WE
DO NOT YET HAVE SUFFICIENT
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE VACCINATED TO
PREVENT FURTHER COMMUNITY
SPREAD OF THE VIRUS. AND
SUSTAINING SUSTAINING OUR
VACCINATION EFFORTS REMAINS
MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUED
COLLABORATION WITH EMERGENCY
RESPONSE AGENCIES TO ACHIEVE
OUR VACCINATION GOALS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU PAUL. AND NOW
LAST FROM OUR FIRST PANEL WILL
HAVE. A SHAUN ROGOFF DIRECTOR
OF SPECIAL OPERATIONS FOR
GLOBAL MEDICAL RESPONSE. GOOD
MORNING. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TO THIS
MANY- AGAIN MY NAME IS GYRO
AFTER AFTER SPECIAL OPERATIONS
FOR GMR- I'VE BEEN WORKING AS-
THE INCIDENT COMMANDER FOR JIM
MARRS COBA NINETEEN RESPONSE
SINCE LAST MARCH OF TWENTY
TWENTY- GMR IN A. M. ARE. AT
ACTIVELY SUPPORTED THE CITIZENS
OF CALIFORNIA FOR THE BEGINNING
OF THE CALL THE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. TO INCLUDE CONTRACTED
SUPPORT OF CALIFORNIA AND STUFF
ARE ALL PATIENT TRANSFERS WILL
GROUND AN ERROR WITHIN THE
STATE AND WORKING CLOSELY WITH
HELLO YES BOTH IN THE FIELD AND
EMBEDDED. IN THE STATE COMMAND
CENTER. WE HAVE WORKED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO PROVIDE
VACCINATION SIDE SUPPORTS
NDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AS A
RESULT WE HAVE THAT BUT MANY OF
OUR EMPLOYEES. ADULT TRAINING
TO BECOME TRAINED INOCULATE
YOURS- WHICH IS A SPECIAL SKILL
SET FOR BOTH FOR BOTH
PARAMEDICS AND EMTS I'D LIKE TO
PROVIDE A QUICK REVIEW. OF SOME
OF OUR AREAS OF SUPPORT WITHIN
THE STATE. I IMPERIAL COUNTY.
WE'VE BEEN SUPPORTING TWELVE
LOCAL VACCINATION SITES SINCE
FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR I WOULD
SEVENTY TWO EMPLOYEES. ACTIVELY
INVOLVED AND WE PROVIDED UP TO-
NINE THOUSAND VACCINATIONS TO
DATE. IN VENTURA COUNTY. MARCH
AS IN WITH FIFTEEN PERSONNEL
MANNING THREE SITES TO IN
OXNARD TO IN CAMERA RIO AND ONE
IN SANTA PAULA. IN SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY I WE'VE HAD
THREE PARAMEDIC INOCULATED IS
WORKING AND RANCHO CUCAMONGA
WE'VE HAD TO AND REDLANDS AND
MAKE THAT TO WORKING IN A
CLINIC IN VICTORVILLE- WE'VE
HAD TO DO AT THE COUNTY
SUPERSITE I'M WORKING AS AN
ARTICULATORS. WE'VE ALSO HAD
PARAMEDICS ON STANDBY ON THE
BACKS AND ASIAN SIDE AT ST
MARY'S HOSPITAL. I IN SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY WE'VE HAD NUMEROUS
SALUS STAND BY UNITS. OF MANY
DIFFERENT VACCINATION SITES. BY
OUR FIRST DATE IN SUPPORT OF
DURING THE INOCULATIONS. IN
CINEMA COUNTY. WE'VE HAD TWENTY
FIVE G. OF OUR EMPLOYEES
INVOLVED IN ASSISTING IN
VACCINATING UP TO FIFTEEN
HUNDRED PEOPLE. IN SACRAMENTO
AND THE GREATER SACRAMENTO
REGION. NOW WE'VE SUPPORTED
VACCINATION CLINICS AND THE LOS
RIOS SCHOOL DISTRICT- AND YOLO
COUNTY WE'VE ACTUALLY STARTED
VERY EARLY SUPPORT IN DECEMBER
OF LAST YEAR WE'VE BEEN PRESENT
AT ALL THE EAGLE COUNTY
VACCINATION CLINICS AS WELL AS
PROVIDING VACCINATIONS SUPPORT
FOR PRIVATE FARMS ARE FOR HIGH
SCHOOLS IN WEST SACRAMENTO AND
YOLO. AND THEN ALSO PROVIDING
SUPPORT FOR HOME BACKS NATION'S
FOR THOSE WHO COULDN'T-
COULDN'T MAKE THEIR WAY TO AN
ACTUAL INOCULATION SITE. I'LL
PROBABLY ARE OUR BIGGEST
SUPPORT EFFORT TO DATE HAS BEEN
IN OAKLAND AT THE OAKLAND
COLISEUM. SUPERSITE THE
VACCINATION SITE THERE I WOULD
BE IN SUPPORT OF THAT OPERATION
AND MID FEBRUARY AND WE ARE
STILL CURRENTLY SUPPORTING IT.
THAT ENERGY OF FORTY TO FIFTY
EMPLOYEES AT THAT LOCATION.
EVERY DAY SEVEN DAYS A WEEK I
HAD AND TO DATE. THE SYSTEM
PROVIDING OVER THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND- VACCINATIONS TO THEIR
COMMUNITY- ONE OF THE ONE OF
THE BIGGER AREAS I THINK WHERE
WE'VE BEEN SUPPORTING
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND THE
SAN DIEGO COUNTY- CHANGE FOR ME
ARE SAN DIEGO ALONG WITH
VOLUNTEERS. FROM THE FAMILY
HEALTH CENTERS OF SAN DIEGO IN
THE LATINO EQUITY COUNCIL I
HAVE GONE DOOR TO DOOR MARIO
LITTLE BIT. TO HELP INFORM
RESIDENTS ABOUT THE VACCINE-
AND GET THEM SIGNED UP FOR
APPOINTMENTS. OUR TEAM TO
PARTICIPATED IN OPERATION
COLLABORATION. WHICH IS AN
EFFORT AIMED TO GETTING THE
VACCINE HOW INTEGRAL
COMMUNITIES. AND IN ADDITION.
TO OPERATING TO FIX SITES IN
THE SAN DIEGO AREA. OUR TEAMS
HAVE ALSO HOSTED A POP UP
CLINICS IN A REAL COMMUNITIES
AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING TO HELP
VACCINATE. COMMUNITIES
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS I'M WHICH
ARE OBVIOUSLY A VERY IMPORTANT
TO THE LOCAL COMMUNITY. WE WILL
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT VACCINATION
OPERATIONS- AS LONG AS THERE IS
A NEED- AN OPPORTUNITY AND I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT OUR OPERATIONS. THANK YOU
SEAN FOR ALL YOUR UPDATE AS
WELL I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
PARTICIPANTS FOR THE FIRST
PANEL AND ON I WANT TO BRING IT
BACK TO OUR MEMBERS FOR
QUESTIONS. I JUST HAVE A QUICK
ONE HERE FOR YOU CHIEF OSBY AND
PARTY FOR SEAN AS WELL ON A LOT
OF OUR LOCAL DEPARTMENTS-
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ARE. OPEN-INTO THIS COMMUNITY
PARAMEDICINE FOR BETTER ACCESS
AND CARE FOR FOLKS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. HOW HAS THAT
PLAYED IMPORTANT ROLE REGARDING
COMMUNITY PARAMEDICINE A LOT OF
OUR DEPARTMENTS ARE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. OF ITS YOU KNOW
CHIEF A LOT OF OUR FIRE STATION
I THINK ANY FIRE STATION BOTH
THE STATE. HAVE AREAS THAT THAT
THEY RESPOND TO THE POLICY A
GREATER NEED FOR BETTER HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. I'M JUST
WONDERING IF FOUGHT THE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE COUNTIES
IN. THE STATE INCHES REALLY
WORK WITH OUR LOCAL AGENCIES TO
MAKE SURE THAT. WE CAN
REGIONALS AFFORDABLE POSS OF.
POPULATION TELLS THAT BEEN
SOMETHING WE WORKED ON IT
SOUNDS LIKE THERE HAS BEEN SOME
WORK THERE. ABOUT JUST ONE
ELABORATE ON EITHER ONE IF YOU
CAN SHARE SOME MORE ON THAT
ISSUE. YEAH THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION AND- WHEN I WAS
SPEAKING EARLIER WHEN WE WERE.
TALK ABOUT OUR COMMUNITY THERE
ARE MANY PROGRAMS ARE. A
CARDIAC ARREST PROGRAMS ARE ARE
VAST PROVIDE RESPONSE UNITS
PROGRAMS AND THOSE PRIMARILY
ARE. COMMUNITIES THAT ARE BUSY
IF THE MEETINGS IN GERMAN
SPEAKING THAT ARE. THE CHINESE
OUR BUSINESS COMMUNITIES ARE
ARE ARE AT RISK COMMUNITIES FOR
ALL ETHNIC GROUPS OR OF COURSE
YOU SHOULD BE ECONOMICALLY
CHALLENGED GROUP THAT HAS
REALLY MATTER WHAT ETHNICITY IS
IN THAT REGARD SO. THAT'S
PROVING TO BE WHILE I'M SERVED
AS IT RELATES TO SERVICES. I'D
LIKE TO BELIEVE THAT. ARE OUT
THERE COULD BE. OF GREATER.
ORDINATION M. KOPPEL WITH THE
STATE MS- AS IT RELATES TO
ALLOWING OF LOCAL AGENCIES TO.
PROVIDE ERIC AND EXPAND THE
SCOPE OF PARAMEDICS- BROADER
FORSBERG BROADER CONVERSATION
FOR PROBABLY ANOTHER MEETING
THERE'S I CAN'T SPEAK FOR LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BECAUSE I HAVE A
GOOD RELATIONSHIP WITH MY LOCAL
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AGENCY BUT I CAN'T SAY FOR MY-
OTHER PARTNERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THERE'S
BEEN CHALLENGES AND CIVIL BASS
TO MANY OF THE- BUT STATE ARE
AND- LOCAL AGENCIES AS IT
RELATES TO THE SCOPE OF
PRACTICE THE PARAMEDICS AND I
THINK. I RESPECTFULLY THAT
CONVERSATION SHOULD BE HAD IN A
DIFFERENT FORM BUT THAT COULD
DEFINITELY BE MORE
COLLABORATION THAT REGARD.
THANK YOU CHIEF ARE SEAN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO ADD ANY TO THE
CONVERSATIONAL COMMITTEE
PERMISSION. I'M SURE- AS FAR AS
THE LOCAL AND STATE M. SAYS- I
FEEL THAT. WE HAD SEVEN BUT WE
HAD TO MOVE PRETTY
AGGRESSIVELY- TO INCREASE THE
SCOPE. FOR PARAMEDICS AND EMTS
WITHIN THE STATE IN ORDER
PROVIDE. APPROPRIATE SUPPORT
FOR VACCINATIONS IN THE OVERALL
RESPONSE AND FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE- WE'VE HAD WE'VE
HAD EXCELLENT SUPPORT FROM BOTH
LOCAL AND CALIFORNIA THEMSELVES
THERE ARE STATE LEVEL ANSWER-
IT TO GET HARD TO GET OUR FOLKS
THAT EXPANDED SCOPE SO THAT WE
CAN GO OUT AND- PROVIDE SUPPORT
FOR THE- FOR THE INOCULATION
OUR MISSION. SO WE'RE WE WE'VE
WE'VE BEEN VERY SATISFIED WITH
THE UP WITH WHAT WE'VE BEEN
GETTING AS FAR SUPPORT FOR THAT.
I THANK YOU ARE COMMITMENT-
PRESSURE CERTAIN A QUESTION.
THANK GOOD MORNING THIS IS A
QUESTION FOR CHEAP OSBI
ACTUALLY A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS.
MORNING CHIEF HOW ARE YOU. THE
MORNING GOING GREAT THANK YOU.
EIGHT SO MY FIRST QUESTION IS
WHEN DID. THE FIRE DEPARTMENT
GET APPROACHED TO START THE
LOGISTICS PROCESS- BECAUSE
EARLY ON THIS IS JUST KIND OF A
NIGHTMARE. AND THE SUGGESTION
WAS THAT WHY DON'T WE LET THE
PEOPLE WHO KNOW HOW TO DO
LOGISTICS BEST. ASSISTANCE IN
THIS AND MIKE I'M KIND OF
CURIOUS WHEN WE STARTED WHEN
YOU GUYS GOT INVOLVED WHEN THEY
APPROACHED YOU- AS THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT- TO GET INVOLVED IN
THE LOGISTICAL- PART OF THIS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION AND
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF LOS GATOS
COUNTY AND MARK. COUNTERPART OF
PUBLIC HEALTH DONALD REGARDING
THE INVOLVEMENT OF THE PACIFIC
LEVEL. I'M WE DISCUSSED THE
DYNAMICS OF THE LOGISTICS OF
SUPPLIES PROVISION TIRE COUNTY.
AND I ADVISED OF MY PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIAL OR DIRECTOR
PUBLIC HEALTH THAT WE HAVE THE
SKILL SETS TO RUN THE- JUST SIX
WORTH APPLYING GOING TO. WORK
OUT NICK NEEDED ASSISTANCE ALSO
PROVIDENCE REPEAT MAP ALL THE
MONSTERS COUNTY FIRE
DEPARTMENT. OR HARDWARE BLOOD
BEACH FIRE DEPARTMENT AND WE
RAN THE ADDITIONAL MAJESTIC'S
OUT OF THE LONG BEACH
CONVENTION CENTER AND WE DID
THAT AND TELL ON. PUBLIC HEALTH
AND HEALTH DEPARTMENT WERE ABLE
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER POINTS-
MANAGE THE SYSTEM AND THEN
OTHER AGENCIES MANAGE THEIR OWN
OTHER SYSTEMS AND SO I THINK
IT'S- A SPEAKS TO BE
COLLABORATION. AND THE
PARTNERSHIPS THAT WE HAVE A LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND THOSE THINGS
ARE. VITALLY IMPORTANT PRIOR TO
THE INCIDENT. I'M IS NOT THE
BEST- HI IN- PRACTICE TO TRY TO
DEVELOP RELATIONSHIPS DON'T
HAVE AN INCIDENT STOKE ESSEX
THE MESSAGE APPEAR BUT WE WERE
INVOLVED IN THE INCIDENT LEVEL.
RIGHT AND WHAT MONTH WAS THAT
INCIPIENT LEVEL. WAS AT LAST
WAS IT AUGUST LAST. YEAR NUMBER
ONE THANK. I'M I'M JUST
GUESSING RIGHT NOW. AB LAST
MARCH OR APRIL WHEN THERE AS
THE CHAIN WITH- BASKET SUPPLY
IN GALA. SO DOES ESTIMATES WAS
MORE OF LAST YEAR WHEN WE BEGAN
TO MAKE INTEL WERE ABLE TO IT
BACK OVER TO THE. MY HOTEL IS I
AM THAT PART FOCUS I THE
VACCINE PART OF THIS. WHEN A
DAY GET YOU YOU. STILL HAVE
TODAY YOU YES. I'M SORRY YEAH
I'M MISUNDERSTOOD YOUR QUESTION.
SO THE DEFINITION PROCESS. ONLY.
I'M TRYING TO THINK AMERICA
NATIONALLY WE WERE INVOLVED IN
THE VACCINES ARM WHEN THERE WAS
A CHALLENGE OF SETTING UP MAKE
MEGA SCIENCE ROBAXIN UNTIL IT
FINALLY CITY SET UP THE FIRST
THIRTY SIX THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES AND THEN WHENEVER THE
DAY WELL IT'S THERE ARE WE
TRANSITION FROM. VACCINES TO
MAKE PROTESTING THE VACCINES
THAT'S WHEN WE BEGAN TO CLEAR
BUT SINCE I DON'T HAVE ACCURATE
DATA PUT IT RIGHT NOW OKAY
VACCINES BECAME AVAILABLE WE
WERE INVOLVED IN THAT MISSION
RIGHT I AND OKAY SO IT IT
BECAUSE THAT'S PART OF MY
QUESTION OR MY CONCERN IS THAT
THEY DIDN'T ENGAGE THE PEOPLE
WHO KNOW HOW TO DO LOGISTICS
PASSED SOON ENOUGH IN THIS
PROCESS WHICH IS WHEN THEY KNOW
THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE
VACCINES ON THE HORIZON AS LATE
R. AS EARLY AS LAST JULY.
THAT'S WHEN THAT PLANNING
PROCESS STARTS AND SO I YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU TRY TO DO LIKE
YOU KNOW YOU KNOW THIS WHEN YOU
TRY TO DO LOGISTICS IN THE
MIDDLE OF A FIRE EIGHT IT'S
PRETTY HECTIC AT THE BEGINNING-
IT'S BETTER IF WE HAVEN'T DONE
WAY AHEAD OF TIME SO THAT THAT
HELPS ME UNDERSTAND THAT ISSUE
A LITTLE BIT- SECOND QUESTION I
HAD AND THEN I'LL LET SOME
OTHERS ANSWERS ASK SOME
QUESTIONS ARE YOU TALK ABOUT
PRE POSITIONING IN THE TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THAT IS
GIVEN. FOR PRE POSITIONING WHAT
KIND OF PRE. IS WAS WITH NO AND
HOW MUCH. WHAT IS THE AMOUNT
NEEDED TO OFFSET THE AGENCY
COSTS JUST FOR L. A. COUNTY
ALONE- SO THAT WE KNOW WHAT
THAT NUMBER IS BECAUSE WE NEED
TO KNOW WHAT ALLOCATIONS ARE
NEEDED IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
ALLOCATE THOSE FROM THE STATE
BUDGET. YEAH SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION SO- ARAMBULA.
REPOSITIONING FUNDS THAT ARE
ALLOCATED- YES IT'S TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS- FOR THE ENTIRE
STATE. I COULDN'T SIT THERE
RIGHT NOW AND TELL YOU WHAT. WE
SHOULD HAVE I MEAN I THOUGHT WE
SHOULD HAVE ASKED FOR. HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AS IT
RELATES TO. THE WALL AND FIRE
RISK AND. RESIDUE AS WE
TRANSITION INTO THE- MAY.
WHATEVER OF BOSTON CAN AND THEN
WAS MODELED ON THE TOWN. UNTIL
THE STATE OVER THERE ARE MY- IS
THAT WE ARE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
WAS FAILING BECAUSE OF THE
SERVERS. SO IF THEY'RE RELATED
TO. THE INVESTIGATION MY
THOUGHT WAS AT THE HOSPITAL
SYSTEMS FAIL. THEN WE GET BY
ONE THOUSAND GOING TO BE
UNABLE. TO TRANSPORT PATIENTS
TO THE EMERGENCY ROOMS SO WHAT
WE DID OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY IS
THERE. WE PARTNERED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH. AND WE
DEVELOPMENT AND IT'S AN ACTUAL
PLAN. CAN WE STARTED PUTTING
CHIEF OFFICERS CAPTAINS AND
PARAMEDICS. AND ENGAGING THEM
HAVE. LOCAL HOSPITALS OF THE
ARTS. TO HELP THEM WITH THEIR
SEARCH. NOW I DID THAT ON MY
OWN DIME BECAUSE LIKE I SAID.
IF I HADN'T DONE THAT THEN
AREN'T WE WHAT WOULD WE
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO COMPLETE
ARGUMENTS MISSION. I DON'T HAVE
A COST FOR THAT RIGHT NOW
BETTER LATER DATE- YES THEY
COME UP WITH THEIR- PLAN. TO
INSERT PARAMEDICS AND- ARMED.
FIREFIGHTERS IN THE HOSPITALS
WHAT I CAN SAY IS THAT PLAN
ALTHOUGH SOMEWHAT EFFECTIVE. IT
WASN'T FORTY MAYBE WHAT THE
LOCAL AGENCIES M. AS A REGIONAL
COORDINATOR OF THE SIX WITH THE
CORNERS AND THE STATE I'VE HAD
MULTIPLE PHONE CALLS. TO YES
THAT'S RIGHT TO MY
PERSPECTIVES- I WON'T SAY THAT
BY PERCENT PERSPECTIVES WERE
COMPLETELY OVERLOOKED. BUT BE
WARNEDCORPORATE IN INTO THE
PLAN. AND THAT'S WHY I SAID I
THINK LATER WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT
LESSONS LEARNED. WE CAN TALK
MORE ABOUT HOW WE CAN BETTER
COLLABORATE. THE FUTURE THAT'S
THAT'S BECAUSE RIGHT NOW OUT
YOU KNOW THIS KIND THEM IS
REALLY A NOMINEE FOR THIS.
GENERATION OF MOST RESPONDENTS.
WELL MAYBE WE CAN GET THE
FINANCE- THE PEOPLE ON THAT
WOULD THAT ISSUE SO THAT WE CAN
MAKE SURE THAT THE AGENCY IS
REIMBURSED AND- IT DOESN'T COME
OUT OF THE POCKETS OF. THE.
FOLKS THAT HAVE DONE ALL THIS
SERVICE I GOING TO. ALLOW
PEOPLE TO GO AHEAD NOW I HAVE
OTHER. BUT ALL LET OTHERS FOR
NOW. ASSEMBLY MEMBER ORDER. YES
THANK YOU I'M THINKING FOR THE
PRESENTATION MORNING AND-
FORMER ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU
AND CALLING- FROM ALL YOU
AGENCY FOR A YEAR OF SERVICE
AND WILL. HAS BEEN OF THE MOST
CHALLENGES- OF YOUR CAREER SO-
SINCERELY THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR DOING AND CONTINUE TO DO.
I HAD QUESTIONS FOR ON BOTH THE
DOCTOR SIMON IN DOCTOR SAYS AND
I THINK FROM A LARGE AND SMALL
COUNTY PERSPECTIVE- YOU KNOW
EFFORT KIND OF THINKING FOR
ABOUT HOW TO REALLY GET THROUGH
HOPEFULLY THESE FINAL MONTHS.
I'M WONDERING HOW YOU'VE BEEN
INTEGRATING YOUR CONTACT
TRACING STRATEGIES AND YOU'RE
SORT OF GETTING THE MESSAGING
OUT THERE THAT TESTING
CONTINUES TO BE REALLY
IMPORTANT. TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE MONITORING FOR- BEING A
POTENTIAL OUTBREAKS POTENTIAL
CLUSTERS- WE KNOW THE CONTACT
TRACING BECAME. MORE RELATIVELY
INEFFECTIVE TOOL AS SURGEONS
WERE HAPPENING BECAUSE IT JUST
BECAME OVERWHELMED BUT NOW
WE'RE BACK IN A STATE WHERE YOU
CAN ACTUALLY START TO ISOLATE
ANY COMMUNITY UP BREAKS- AND
THEN FURTHER MORE YOU KNOW WHAT
WE'RE SEEING AND I'M CONCERNED
WITH UP IN EUREKA- AND HUMBLE
COUNTY I KNOW NEITHER OF YOU-
REPRESENT THAT BUT- DO YOU HAVE
SORT OF CONTINGENCY PLANS.
PREPARED SHOULD YOU START TO BE
ABLE TO IDENTIFY A SIGNIFICANT
CLUSTER A COMMUNITY OPERATE TO
REALLY KEEP THAT CONTAINED. I'M
HAPPY TO START THIS IS SOFTBALL
SIMON L. A. COUNTY- WELL WE
YEAH WE REMAIN VERY COMMITTED
TO- CONTACT TRACING AND IN
FACT. NOW IT'S BECOME MORE
MANAGEABLE WITH THE NUMBERS
BEING DOWN. WHERE THEY ARE AT
THE HEIGHT OF THE SURGE I MEAN
WE REALLY HAD TO- YOU KNOW JUST
CONTINUE A LOT OF- THOSE.
EFFORTS SO IT REMAINS A
PRIORITY- NOT ONLY. ARE TO HELP
FOLKS. GET TESTED AND TO GET
THE OTHER SERVICES THEY NEED
BUT ALSO WE VIEW IT AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
VACCINE HESITANCY ISSUE- WE ARE
HEARING- FROM A NUMBER OF OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS THAT ONE.
REASON WHY SOME ARE- DECIDING
NOT TO BE VACCINATED IS BECAUSE
THEY'VE ALREADY HAD INFECTION
THAT JUST DON'T THINK- THAT
VACCINATION THEREFORE IS NEEDED
AND SO. WERE UP WE'RE REALLY.
URGING THEM FROM TO BE
VACCINATED AS PART OF OUR
CONTACT RAISING OUR CASE
INVESTIGATION WORK AND THEN AS
WE REACH OUT TO CONTACTS UP
LIKE WISE TO DO THE SAME AND
THEN ONCE WE DO VACCINATE
PEOPLE NOW URGING THEM TO
ENCOURAGE THEIR FRIENDS AND-
FAMILY MEMBERS TO BE
VACCINATED- TO THE UP TO THE
ISSUE THE OUTBREAK CONTROL.
BEEN THAT REALLY IS BRAND
BETTER PUBLIC HEALTH AND I
THINK AS VACCINATION COVERAGE.
RATES CONTINUE TO INCREASE AND
HOPEFULLY CASE UMBERS CONTINUE
TO GO DOWN WILL BE ABLE TO
TREAT THIS. AND ETHNIC- MORE
LIKE WE TREAT OTHER
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES WHERE WE
DO HAVE A VERY VIGOROUS. TOP
RESPONSE- TO THE TO OPERATE
CONTROL. YEAH THIS IS DOCTOR
SAYS THAT I DON'T I DON'T HAVE
TOO MUCH TO ADD TO IT WILL IT
DR SIMON SAID ALL MADE IN YOLO
COUNTY WE CONTINUED MESSAGE THE
IMPORTANCE OF TESTING I THINK
EVERY TIME I GIVE A
PRESENTATION AND SPEAK WITH THE
MEDIA THAT IT'S THAT IS ONE OF
MY MESSAGES IS ESPECIALLY FOR
THOSE WHO REMAIN UNVACCINATED
THE IMPORTANCE OF TESTING WE'VE
BEEN PARTNERING WITH HEALTHY
DAVIS TOGETHER WHICH IS DOING
EXTENSIVE TESTING IN THE- IN
THE CITY OF DAVIS AND ALSO THAT
THE UNIVERSITY DOING EXTENSIVE
TESTING OF ITS DICKINSON AND
STAFF. AND SOME OF THEIR OR
THEIR DEEPER POCKETS AND-
WORKING WITH THEIR MARKETING
COMPANY TO HELP ADVERTISE- OUR
OPTUM CERTAIN OTHER TESTING
SITES AND ALSO EMPHASIZING
TESTING IT IN OUR MIGRANTS-
WORKER A COMMUNITIES WHO
RECENTLY ARRIVED IN INYO COUNTY
FOR THIS YEAR AND START GROWING
SEASON- SO THAT'S DEFINITELY A
BIG PIECE OF WHAT WE CONTINUE
TO DO IS GETTING THE WORD OUT
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
TESTING- WE ARE SIMILAR TO L.
A. COUNTY EXPERIENCED
CHALLENGES KEEPING UP WITH THE
SURGE IN TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF
CASES AND HOW TO PRIORITISE.
WHICH CASES RECEIVE FULL CASE
INVESTIGATION AND CONTACT
TRACING THAT'S NO LONGER THE
CASE WERE ABLE TO DO A FULL
CASE INVESTIGATION AND CONTACT
TRACING ON EVERY CASE- BUT WE
RELY HEAVILY ON A BORROWED
STAFF FROM THE STATE'S
REDIRECTS I BELIEVE WE HAVE
FIFTY ONE THE STATE RE DIRECTS
OR ASSISTING WITH THE CASE
INVESTIGATION AND CONTACT
TRACING AND YOLO COUNTY- WERE
HEARING THAT THEIR THEIR
MISSION. MAY AND THE IN THE
MIDDLE OF JUNE AND SO PLANNING
FOR THAT TRANSITION AND ALSO
LEVERAGING A SOME OF THE RECENT
FUNDING COMING FROM THE STATE
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
STAFF UP OUR YOU'LL COUNTY
STAFF TO FILL IN BEHIND THE
STATE REDIRECTS WHEN THEY
RETURN TO THEIR THEIR THEIR DAY
JOB SO TO SPEAK SO A LOT OF US
STAFFING. SHIFTS HAPPENING ON
ALL BY. BUT CAUGHT- WITH EACH
THE YOUR COUNTIES THE AS WELL
AS THE STATE REDIRECTS FOR THE
TIME BEING THAT WE CAN DO A
FULL CASE INVESTIGATION AND
CONTACT TRACING. ABOVE ROUTINE
CASES AS WELL AS IN OUTBREAK
SITUATIONS. OKAY GREAT THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER IGOR
KOREAN QUESTION YEAH GOOD
MORNING AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
PUTTING THIS TOGETHER TODAY AS
WELL THANK YOU TO FROM THE
BOTTOM OF MY HEART FOR ALL OF
THE PRISONERS TODAY FOR WHAT
YOU'VE DONE FOR OUR COMMUNITIES
AND OUR CONSTITUENTS. BUT THE
QUESTION I HAVE IS DIRECTED TO
A DR SASAN- FIRST OF ALL I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR WHAT
YOU'VE DONE FOR YELL COUNTY AND
HOW MANY OF OUR CONSTITUENTS
ARE VACCINATED. BUT I DO HAVE
QUESTIONS THAT COME UP IN I
WANTED TO SIGNAL ITS FIRST OF
ALL YOU'RE RIGHT SMALL COUNTIES
ARE MORE FLEXIBLE- AND NIMBLE
AND CAN PIVOT QUICKLY. AND I
THINK THAT WE WERE PUT IN AN
AWKWARD SITUATION WE WERE
TRYING TO GET- MY TURN UP AND-
IT KIND OF I THINK WAS A HICK
UP NOT FOR. OUR SYSTEM I THINK
SHE DID THAT HER DEPARTMENT
DIDN'T INCREDIBLE JOB BUT-
HAVING TO PIVOT WAS. WAS
DIFFICULT I THINK AND IT TOOK A
LOT OF TIME AWAY FROM. THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING IS GETTING
VACCINATIONS OUT TOWARD OUR
PEOPLE- THE QUESTION I HAVE
THIS COME UP WITH JUST FRIENDS
AND FAMILY. IS THAT HOW DO WE
KNOW AND THIS COULD BE PROBABLY
ANSWERED BY ANYONE. HOW DO WE
KNOW OUR NUMBERS ARE ACCURATE
FOR AT VACCINATIONS BECAUSE- I
HAVE REALLY GOOD FRIENDS OF
MINE. THE LIVING YOLO COUNTY
THEY GOT VACCINATIONS AND
SOLANO COUNTY. I HAVE VERY GOOD
FRIENDS OF MINE. ARE THAT THE-
GOT VACCINATIONS IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY HOW WAS UP INFORMATION-
PUT TOGETHER SO THAT WE KNOW
THAT OUR ACTUAL NUMBERS FOR
YOLO COUNTY. ARE INCLUSIVE OF
THOSE OTHER COUNTIES WHERE
FRIENDS AND FAMILY HAVE GONE
OUT OF OUR COUNTY FOR THE
VACCINATIONS. YEAH BUT BUT
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION AND IT
REALLY COMES DOWN TO HOW YOU
QUERY THE DATABASES- BUT WE DO
CAPTURE THE ADDRESS OF THE
PERSON WHO'S BEING VACCINATED
NOT JUST THE LOCATION WHERE
THEY ARE BEING VACCINATED SO
WHEN OPPORTUNITY NEUROLOGISTS
GOES INTO THE SNOW FLAKE
DATABASE ARE. TO RUN THE DATA
YOU'LL COUNTY RESIDENTS WHO
WERE BACKS WHO'VE BEEN
VACCINATED TO DATE THAT IS
BASED OFF ON THE ADDRESSES- SO
WHETHER YOU'RE A YOU'LL COUNTY
RESIDENT WHO GETS VACCINATED IN
SOLANO COUNTY OR IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY WHEN WE QUERY BY
ADDRESS- FOR YOLO COUNTY WE
WILL FIND YOU- SO YOU WON'T
SHOW UP AS BEING VACCINATED BY
YOLO COUNTY- BUT YOU WILL SHOW
UP AS A YOLO COUNTY RESIDENTS-
AND SO. YOU WILL BE IN IN OUR
DATA- SO YOU CAN BE YOU CAN BE
CONFIDENT THAT- AS LONG AS YOU
LIST YOUR CORRECT ADDRESS OF
RESIDENTS IT WILL YOUR
VACCINATION WILL BE ATTRIBUTED
TO YOUR COUNTY OF RESIDENCE.
NOT THE COUNTY WHERE YOU ARE
VACCINATED. HELLO THAT I KALRA
WITH YOU BUT INITIALLY I THINK
WITH SOME FRIENDS THE FAMILY
DID NOT NECESSARY PUT THE RIGHT
ADDRESS ON THERE SO THAT THEY
CAN GET THE- VACCINATION IN
ANOTHER COUNTY. SO I UNDERSTAND
THAT- AND LASTLY HOW CAN WE
HELP YOU- I THINK ABOUT ALL THE
PEOPLE THAT THINK THAT NOW THAT
THEY'VE HAD THE VACCINATION
THAT THEY DON'T NEED TO BE
TESTED. AND SO AS THE
LEGISLATURE WHAT CAN I DO FOR
YOU. TO HELP THAT MOVE ALONG
BECAUSE UP I AGREE THAT YOU ARE
DOING A GREAT JOB DAVIS HAS A
GREAT WEBSITE THAT COMMERCIAL.
BUT STILL PEOPLE ARE HESITANT
THEY FIGURE THEY'RE DONE- WHAT
CAN WE DO FOR YOU. WELL THAT
THANK YOU FOR THAT I UP
APPRECIATE THE OFFERS WHAT I
THINK THAT THE BIGGEST SUPPORT
THAT. ARE MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY AND OTHERS I CAN
PROVIDE IT IS REALLY IN THE
ECHOING THE MESSAGES THE THAT
WERE PUTTING OUT FROM. FROM OUR
HEALTH DEPARTMENT SEVEN AND
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT AGENCY IS-
PARTICULARLY AROUND VACCINATION
EMPHASIZING THAT IT IS. THAT IT
IS SAFE THAT IS THAT IT IS
EFFECTIVE THAT IT'S FREE AND
THAT IT'S WIDELY AVAILABLE. I'M
ONE OF THE SORT OF MIXED
BLESSINGS OF THE CURRENT
SITUATION WHERE WE HAVE MORE
SUPPLY THAN DEMAND- IT IS THAT
IT'S NOW EASIER TO GET A
VACCINE THAN IT EVER. HAS BEEN
AND SO I THINK SHARING THAT
NEWSLETTER I THINK SOME PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN WAITING NOT WANTING
TO HAVE TO STAY ON THE LINE.
ALL OR HALF OF TO FIGHT AND
JOCKEY FOR A VACCINE BY
REFRESHING THE BROWSER EVERY
FIVE MINUTES- IF YOU KNOW
PEOPLE LIKE THAT NOW IS THE NOW
IS THEIR TIME THE PERSONAL
LINE- SO ENCOURAGING THOSE
WHO'VE BEEN WAITING TO GET
VACCINATED BUT ALSO. JUST IT
REALLY PUSHING THE MESSAGES
ABOUT THAT THE SAFETY OF THE
EFFECTIVENESS. AND THE NO COST
NATURE OF. THE VACCINES. REALLY
OUR OUR TECH OUT OF PANDA. YEAH
IN MY LAST COURSE IS THAT- I
PRE. THE MOBILE. OF SERVICES
CLINICS THAT HAVE BEEN USED
PARTICULAR FOR FARMWORKERS- AND
I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL WORKING WITH THE
FARMERS IN YOLO COUNTY. I'D
LOVE FOR YOU TO DO LESSONS
LEARNED WITH SOME OF MY CENTRAL
VALLEY FRIENDS. THAT ARE
STRUGGLE HAVE STRUGGLED TRYING
TO GET THE FARMWORKERS-
VACCINATE I'M SURE YOU HAVE
BUT- I HEAR THAT QUITE A BIT
FROM MY CONSTITUENTS A
DIFFERENT MEETINGS THAT THEY'RE
THEY'RE FARMWORKERS ARE NOT
BEING- VACCINATED SO- JUST AS
THE- LOVE FOR YOU TO SHARE. OUR
LESSONS LEARNED WHAT'S BEEN THE
SUCCESS INYO COUNTY. AND THANK
YOU FOR ALL YOUR SERVICE I
APPRECIATED. WHAT THAT I WANT
TO THANK ALL OF OUR A MEMBER
FROM OUR FIRST PANEL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
PARTICIPATION. NOW YOU HAVE ONE
MORE QUESTION. OF UP TO ONE AND
ONE MORE QUESTION FOR GOING
SECOND HIM YET BECAUSE THIS IS
IMPORTANT FOR THE FUTURE
BECAUSE OUR JOB IS TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO DO THIS BETTER IN
THE FUTURE AND I THINK- AND
THIS CAN BE FOR. ANY OR ALL OF
THE PEOPLE. WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THE COMMUNITIES THAT WORK WE
WERE STRUGGLING TO GET TAKE A
DATE TO GET VACCINATED. THERE
IS IT'S EITHER  LACK OF ACCESS
OR LACK OF WILLINGNESS TO
PARTICIPATE. RIGHT NOW WE ARE
WITH THE MARKET IS FLOODED WITH
VACCINATIONS AND SO WE SHOULD
BE ABLE TO DISTINGUISH WHAT IS
OUR BIGGER CHALLENGE. BEFORE I
WAS TOLD WELL IT'S KIND A
LITTLE OF BOTH I UNDERSTAND
THAT IT'S A LITTLE VOTES BUT
IT'S EIGHTY TWENTY OR SO WHAT
IS THE BIGGEST. THE BIGGEST
OBSTACLE TO GETTING THOSE
COMMUNITIES THERE DISADVANTAGED.
THE VACCINATION IS IT A LACK OF
WILLINGNESS OR LACK OF ACCESS.
WE COULD START WITH G. BONTA
BEYOND THAT. OKAY THINK AYE
SAMMY YES WE CAN ACHIEVE OKAY
YEAH SO I'M NOT THE EXPERT IS
THE RELATES TO VACCINATIONS
BUT- I'LL GIVE YOU MY
PERSPECTIVE- FIRST. THIS IS THE
LACK OF ACCESS. ARM I THINK
THERE WHEN YOU LOOK AT ANY.
COMMUNITY AND IN OUR COUNTY.
THAT WAS CHALLENGE. PRIOR TO
THE PANDEMIC IT'S A PLACE TO
ACCESS FOR HEALTHCARE OR OTHER
SERVICES. OUR THAT WAS THE
SITUATION. PREDATED COVERT
NINETEEN AND SO WHAT COOPER
NINETEEN OF HER. THERE'S THAT
CHANGED OTHER THAN THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE HOPE NINETEENTH OF
THE MOST ST COMMUNITIES THAT
STRUGGLED FOR- HEALTH CARE
ACCESS. OR PARTICLE ANYTHING
WITH THE SAME COMMUNITIES THERE
IT'S STRUGGLING NOW. AND THAT'S
THE SUM A LARGE. ARM STRATEGIC
APPROACH TO HOW WE ADDRESS
THAT- MOVING FORWARDS- SILVA
REYES TO VACCINES NOW I THINK
IT'S AN ADDITIONAL ACCESS I
THINK ITS WILLING THIS. I'M
GONNA WE HAVE CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES THERE ARE ARE ARE
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE BAD
THING I THINK THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUOUSLY PROMOTE THE
VACCINATION PROCESS AND TALK
ABOUT THE BENEFITS OF THE
VACCINE AND IT ALSO COME UP
WITH A STRATEGY. TO WORK WITH A
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS TO
GET AS MANY PEOPLE ELIGIBLE FOR
HEALTH CARE MEDICARE AND HALF
PROFESSIONAL HEALTH DISEASE OR
VENDORS- GO TWO THESE ARE ALSO
A PUBLIC COMPANY I BELIEVE THAT
THOSE OF EXPERTS. ALSO TO
IMPROVE THE- GET HOME DEPOT
COMMITTEE THE COMMUNITY TO GET
BACK TO DONE I KNOW. WAS MADE
EARLIER. IN SOME WE'RE GOING
THE PART. THE SYSTEM OF THE OWN
VACCINE. OF PROCESS AND FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE AS THE PARTY BUT I
BELIEVE IT WAS THE MOST
EFFECTIVE USE OF OUR
PARAMEDICS- YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE MISSING THEM I'M
NINETY ONE MISSION. AND THEY
WERE GETTING INTO THE FIRE
SEASON BUT I BELIEVE IT'S AN
ABERRATION WITH OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH AGENCIES. TOP AGENCIES
AND- PRIVATE ENTITIES AND
VENDORS TO BETTER PROVIDE
ACCESS TO COMMUNITIES. IN NEED
FOR VACCINES. I AM VERY GOOD
CHIEF THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
WE'LL DO AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE UP.
HERE TO HELP YOU GUYS WITH THE
WILDFIRE SEASON TO. ANYONE ELSE
WOULD LIKE TO A TO THAT BEFORE
MOVING TO THE NEXT. WITH THAT
SAID ONCE AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
ALL OF OUR PARTICIPANTS ONCE
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR. ALL THE
WORK YOU DO AND DAY OUT AND
OVERSEE THIS JUST THE
BEGINNING. THE PANDEMIC- HAS
REALLY TAKEN US TO A DIFFERENT-
LEVEL AS WE PROVIDE CARE AND
SERVICES TO. FOLKS WITHIN THE
STATE. ALSO WITHOUT- ONCE AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR HELP IN YOUR
TESTIMONY. AS WE MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT PANEL SO WITH THAT. WE'LL
BEGIN OUR SECOND PANEL WILL
BEGIN WITH DOCTOR DAVE DUNCAN.
DIRECTOR OF EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES AUTHORITY. DR DUNCAN.
A GOOD GOOD MORNING FOLKS YOU
HEAR ME OK YES WE'RE HERE. I
DIDN'T GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MR VICE CHAIRMAN AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK THIS
MORNING. I'M DOCTOR DAVE DUNCAN
I'M EMERGENCY PHYSICIAN AND THE
DIRECTOR OF AMPS- THE
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES AUTHORITY. AND IT'S
ABSOLUTELY MY PLEASURE TO COVER
MANY OF THE RESPONSES AND
PARTICIPATION IN HAMPSHIRE HAS
PROVIDED. A THROUGHOUT THIS
PANDEMIC RESPONSE. BOB I'LL
JUST DIVE RIGHT IN IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE THE CALIFORNIA EMS
SYSTEM WAS CREATED THROUGH THE
ADOPTION OF HEALTH AND SAFETY
CODE VERSION TWO POINT FIVE
WITH THE INTENT OF CREATING A
COORDINATED STATEWIDE.
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
SYSTEM TYPICALLY CALLED EMS
SYSTEMS OF COURSE M. SAYS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
COORDINATION AND INTEGRATION OF
ALL STATE ACTIVITIES CONCERNING
IN US TO ENSURE THE PROVISION
OF EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT
EMERGENCY MEDICAL CARE. HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE DIRECTS UPSET
TO RESPOND TO ANY MEDICAL
DISASTER BY MOBILIZING AND
COORDINATING EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES- AND MUTUAL AID
RESOURCES TO MITIGATE HEALTH
PROBLEMS. INTO MAINTAINS THE
STATE'S MOBILE MEDICAL ASSETS
PROGRAM TO SUPPORT LOCAL
RESPONSE NEEDS. THE STATE IN
ACCORDANCE WITH CALIFORNIA'S
STANDARDIZED EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM MORE SAM'S.
THE THIS MMA PROGRAM IS
COMPRISED OF MANY CONSTITUENTS
INCLUDING ADULT STRIKE TEAMS
MEDICAL TASK FORCE PROGRAMS
FUNDED DISASTER MEDICAL SUPPORT
UNIT PROGRAM FREQUENTLY CALLED
THE DAM SU PROGRAM. OF FORTY
TWO VEHICLE STRATEGICALLY
PLACED THROUGHOUT THE STATE. OF
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSISTANCE TEAM. PROGRAMMER CAL
MATS. IT SHOULD SUPPORT TEAM
PRO. MOBILE MEDICAL SHELTER
PROGRAM FORMALLY THE MOBILE
MEDICAL FIELD HOSPITAL PROGRAM.
IT'S A CONTINUES TO SUPPORT
RESPONSE ACTIVITIES FOR COCA
NINETEEN WHICH BEGAN
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE THAN A YEAR
AGO JANUARY TWENTY FOURTH
TWENTY TWENTY WITH THE
ACTIVATION OF THE MEDICAL
HEALTH COORDINATION CENTER
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THE MH CC
AND SHORTLY AFTER THAT THE
STATE OPERATIONS CENTER- IN MID
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY AMPS
ACTIVATED. OUR DEPARTMENT
OPERATIONS CENTER OR DOC TO
SUPPORT STATEWIDE MEDICAL
OPERATIONS IN COAL AT THE
EMERGENCY SUPPORT FUNCTION
EIGHT ESFA MULTI AGENCY
COORDINATION GROUP FOR SCARCE
RESOURCE ALLOCATION AND POLICY
GUIDANCE TO RESPOND TO COVER
NINETEEN. OUR RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES INCLUDE- WE BEGAN
REALLY OUR BOOTS ON THE GROUND
ACTIVITIES WITH SUPPORT OF THE
REPATRIATION FLIGHTS AND
PARTICULARLY THE GRANT PRINCESS
EVACUATION- DURING WHICH WE
WERE CHARGED WITH THE MEDICAL
EVALUATION AND EVACUATION OF
FOLKS FROM THE SHIP. I WE WORK
WITH OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS IN A
WE ASK PARTNERS TO ACCOMPLISH
THAT GOAL THIS INCLUDING
INCLUDED THE COORDINATION OF
SEVEN SEVEN AMBULANCE STRIKE
TEAMS- TOTALING MORE THAN FORTY
AMBULANCES. AGREE WHICH WE
TRANSPORTED- A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE PEOPLE EIGHTY TWO
OF THOSE BEING PAIENCE-
DISSEMINATED TO NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS. WE
PROVIDED SUPPORT TO FEDERAL
MEDICAL STATIONS ALTERNATE CARE
SITES AND LONG TERM FACILITIES
THROUGHOUT THE RESPONSE WE'VE
DEPLOYED WE DEPLOYED OVER NINE
HUNDRED CALVET MEMBERS- MANY OF
THOSE ON MULTIPLE DEPLOYMENTS
TOTALING OVER THIRTY SEVEN
HUNDRED. INDIVIDUAL MEMBER
DEPLOYMENTS TO SUPPORT A
HUNDRED THIRTEEN MEDICAL
MISSIONS PROVIDING CARE FOR
OVER EIGHTY SIX HUNDRED
PATIENTS- WE'VE PROVIDED
ALTERNATE CARE FACILITIES WITH.
WHAT'S KNOWN AS POLLS THAT IS
OUR PATIENT UNIFIED LOOKUP
SYSTEM FOR EMERGENCIES THAT'S
ENABLE FOLKS WORKING IN THOSE
SPACES YOU HAVE IMMEDIATE
ACCESS. TO- PATIENT HEALTHCARE
INFORMATION. BOB SINCE OF OUR
EIGHT OF OUR H. H. ID PROGRAM.
UP ONE OF THE BIGGEST- PIECES
OF OUR SUPPORT HIS BAND MEDICAL
STAFFING SUPPORT TO HOSPITALS.
I AM SO WAS TASKED WITH
COORDINATING THE APPROVAL OF
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS COMING
FROM OUT OF STATE IN THE
CALIFORNIA. AND WE'VE DONE THAT
FOR OVER THIRTY TWO THOUSAND
OUT OF STATE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS SO THAT THEY
COULD PROVIDE CARE IN
CALIFORNIA. FOR THE CODE
NINETEEN RESPONSE UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER TO
DO SO- THERE BEEN CURRENT DEAL
CURRENTLY FORTY FOUR HUNDRED
CONTRACTS STAFF SUPPORTING A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE MEDICAL
FACILITIES. IN FORTY ONE
COUNTIES- THE PEAK BACK IN
JANUARY WAS SUPPORT FOR TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
FACILITIES WITH OVER SIX
THOUSAND PROVIDERS- JUST
CARRYING THIS MESSAGE JOHN- IN
SUPPORT FOR HOSPITAL MEDICAL
SURGEON A MORE GENERAL SENSE-
WE'VE ASSISTED THIRTEEN
HOSPITALS THROUGH CALIFORNIA
WITH DIRECT EXPANSION OF THEIR
ICY USE BY PROVIDING INCREASED
EQUIPMENT AND PERSONNEL WE
DEPLOYED AND MANAGED OVER FORTY
MOBILE MEDICAL SHELTER
STRUCTURES OF FORMAL FORMALLY-
PORTIONS OF THE MOBILE FIELD
HOSPITALS- WE HAVE ESTABLISHED.
A FIFTY BED MOBILE FIELD
HOSPITAL IN THE PARKING LOT
IT'LL CENTER REGIONAL MEDICAL
CENTER- WE HAVE STRATEGICALLY
DEPLOYED BEFORE KOBE IT'S A
MOBILE MEDICAL SHELTER MODULES
WHICH INCLUDE SIX STRUCTURES
EACH CLUSTER ABOUT MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT OF THOSE HAVE BEEN%
DEPLOYED TO RIVERSIDE LONG
BEACH SANTA CRUZ SAN MATTEO IN
SACRAMENTO TO REACH ANALYZE THE
SUPPORT MECHANISM FOR
EMERGENCIES AND THAT PROVED
ESSENTIAL DURING THE CODE
RESPONSE WE ALSO DEPLOYED
ANOTHER MODULE OF SIX TO MERCED
COUNTY. EARLY IN THE CODE
RESPONSIBLE STILL- BOLSTER.
LOCAL MEDICAL SEARCH CAPABILITY
THERE. WE STAB A OUR DEPOTS IN
CALIFORNIA. TO SUPPORT A
CRITICAL OXYGEN SHORTAGES IN
HOSPITALS- I'M SURE- YES WILL
COVER BUT- WE PARTNERED WITH
SEVERAL STATE AGENCIES TO
SUPPORT- TO SUPPORT WITH
HOSPITALS ON MANY LEVELS
INCLUDING VERY LARGE SCALE OF
SUPPLEMENTAL OXYGEN SYSTEMS FOR
HOSPITALS. THAT PROVIDED ONSITE
AN ONGOING DAILY TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO POOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES AND THEIR
HOSPITAL SYSTEMS- WE HAD BOOTS
ON THE GROUND- IN THOSE
COUNTIES THAT HELPING TO
PROVIDE DIRECT ASSISTANCE TO
THE MOST NEEDY HOSPITALS-
PROVIDED CRITICAL MEDICAL
SUPPLIES TO LOCAL HOSPITALS AND
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS. IT'S A
BECAME THE HUB FOR ALL STATE
PROCURED VENTILATORS IV PUMPS
HIGH FLOW NASAL CANNULA BI PAP
AND OTHER DURABLE MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT- WE DEPLOYED OVER
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED VENTILATORS
TO MEDICAL FACILITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
CORRECTLY OF. SORRY. WHAT KIND
OF PHONE CALL THERE I
APOLOGIZE- WE CURRENTLY HAVE.
FIFTEEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
VENTILATOR UNITS READY FOR
IMMEDIATE DEPLOYMENT WE DID
DEPLOY APPROXIMATELY TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED OF THOSE VENTILATOR SO
VENTILATOR TO OF MEDICAL
FACILITIES AND COUNTIES TO- PRE
DEPLOY OF LOCATIONS. IT
LOCATIONS FOR VENTILATORS SO
THAT THEY'D BE UP- ULTIMATELY A
BETTER PREPARED TO DEPLOY THOSE
ARE FROM THE COUNTY LOCATIONS
WE PROVIDED KOPET TESTING IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL GUARD THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THE OVERALL ANSWER
PROVIDED TWENTY THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOUR TESTS TO SUPPORT
THE CENTRAL VALLEY MONTEREY-
TULARE COUNTY AND OTHERS WE
PROVIDED MEDICAL SUPPORT DURING
THE UNPRECEDENTED US STATEWIDE
WILDFIRES DURING THE COVERT
RESPONSE. FROM JULY THROUGH
OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY. A DURING
THAT TIME WE ESTABLISHED
MEDICAL SUPPORT OFFER
OPERATIONS AT TWENTY FOUR
CALIFORNIA BASED CAPS- WE
ESTABLISHED A MEDICAL SHELTER
IN SANTA CRUZ TO SUPPORT FIRE
EVACUATIONS AS WELL. WE
PROVIDED CALIFORNIA VACCINATION
SUPPORTS ON A NUMBER OF FRONTS-
FIRST UPSET ESTABLISHED SIX
VACCINATION TASK FORCE TEAMS TO
WORK IN JUNCTION WITH OUR
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD
PARTNERS. THESE WERE SIX EIGHT
MEMBER TEAM CONSISTING OF OUR
ANDS PARAMEDICS EMTS AND WE
SUPPORTED TWENTY VACCINATION
SITES WITH APPROXIMATELY FORTY
TWO THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
VACCINATIONS PROVIDED. THROUGH
THAT ONE SERVICE- ARE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CORES WHICH
ANSWER HAS ON BOARDED SUPPORTED
NINE SITES AND IS COVERED FOUR
HUNDRED AND THREE SHIPS- FOR
VACCINATION. SO SUPPORTED
MEDICAL OPERATIONS ADDRESS- TO
FEMA PODS- INCLUDING THE
OAKLAND IN L. A. LOCATIONS HAVE
SAYS DEVELOPS LOCAL OPTIONAL
SCOPES OF PRACTICE. UNDER
EXECUTIVE ORDER FOR EMTS AND
PARAMEDICS TO ADMINISTER BALL
INFLUENZA AND COBIT VACCINES
AND THIS IS BEEN ADOPTED BY
EVERY ONCE A LOCAL EMS AGENCY.
IN THE STATE'S MARKEDLY
EXPANDING THE POOL OF
CALIFORNIA VACCINATORS
AVAILABLE. MS HAS WORKED WITH
LAPSES TO RECRUIT AND TRAIN
AVAILABLE PARAMEDICS ADVANCED
EMTS AND EMTS TO SUPPORT
VACCINATION CLINICS. WIDE
MINISTRY BACKS NATIONS
THEMSELVES CURRENTLY WORKING
WITH CDPH LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND THE THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR. TO DEPLOY A
VACCINATION PROGRAM FOR THE
HOME BALANCE BUT WE EXPECT THIS
TO BE KICKED OFF BY THE END OF
THIS WEEK THIS WILL UTILIZED
EMS AND AMBULANCE STRIKE TEAMS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. TO HELP
DELIVER COBIT VACCINATION TO
THE HOMEBOUND IN THOSE COUNTIES
THAT REQUESTS- SAID ASSISTANCE
MANY YOU'E TAKING THIS ON BUT
THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT WILL BE
AVAILABLE TO ALL COUNTIES. WE
CALL THIS PROGRAM THE VAST
PROGRAM FOR ACTION AND
FASCINATION AMBULANCE. STRIKE
TEAM PROGRAM. WE ARE ALSO
CURRENTLY BOARD SUPPORT FOR. IN
A COUNTY WE'VE BEEN DOING THAT
FROM THREE SEVENTEEN TO
PRESENCE. IN THAT ONE COUNTY WE
SCREENED OVER THIRTEEN HUNDRED
CLIENTS WE PROVIDED ONGOING
CARE IN THE FORM OF WELLNESS
CHECKS TESTING. PER STATE PER
BOWL COBIT SUSPECTED AND COPE
WITH POSITIVE CLIENTS IN THAT
SPACE AND THAT- THAT MISSION IS
EXPANDING INTO RIVERSIDE AND
OTHER COUNTIES CURRENTLY. I'M
GONNA COVER OR SUCCESSES
BRIEFLY AND THEN TALK ABOUT
SOME AREAS- FOR AFTER ACTION
IMPROVEMENT OF SOME OF THE
SUCCESSES INCLUDED STATE WHY
COMMUNICATIONS. WE'VE HAD
STRONG COMMUNICATIONS WITH
LOCAL STATE FEDERAL PARTNERS WE
CONDUCTED REGULAR MEETINGS WITH
LOCAL STATE PARTNERS TO DISCUSS
TRENDS PROTOCOLS EMS GUIDANCE
BEST PRACTICES. AND IMPROVEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. I CAN'T HELP BUT
JUMP TO THE AFTER ACTION
REPORTING HERE- BASED ON- CHIEF
OSPREYS COMMENTS AND- AND I
CAN'T AGREE MORE- WHEN
EVERYBODY IS WORKING AND THIS
IS ALL AGENCIES LOCAL STATE
FEDERAL. WHEN EVERYBODY'S
WORKING THIS HARD ONE OF THE
pIN LAST PLACE IS MEDICATION AND
THAT'S AN AREA WE CAN ALWAYS
IMPROVE ON AND WE ARE LOOKING
FOR WAYS. TO MAKE SURE WE
OPTIMIZE THAT OFTEN- FUTURE
MISSION RESPONSES- OTHER
SUCCESSES CAL MATT HAS BEEN- I
THINK AN AMAZING SUCCESS FOR
US. BEFORE CO WITH THE CALUMET
PROGRAM HAD APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED MEMBERS IT'S A GREAT
THIS PROGRAM TO OVER TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED MEMBERS. BY LEVERAGING
THE GOVERNOR'S CALL TO ACTION
SECURING INCREASED NUMBERS OF
CANDIDATES FROM SOCIAL MEDIA-
AND RECRUITMENT POSTERS.
SUPPORT THE COVER NINETEEN
RESPONSE. SEDATE ABSOLUTE OVER
NINE CALUMET MEMBERS ON THIRTY
SEVEN HUNDRED DEPLOYMENTS AGAIN
TO SUPPORT OVER A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MEDICAL MISSIONS.
INCLUDING THE TWENTY TWENTY
WILDFIRE RESPONSE. MEMBERS ARE
ALSO BEING UTILIZED TO SUPPORT
STATEWIDE PUBLIC VACCINATION
CLINICS. THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCOR PROGRAM WAS CREATED
TO RECRUIT LICENSED MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS INCLUDING
RETIREES USING THE DISASTER
HEALTHCARE VOLUNTEER SYSTEM TO
SUPPORT THE COVER NINETEEN
RESPONSE. SINCE THE INCEPTION
OF THE GOVERNOR'S INITIATIVE
PROGRAM APRIL TWENTY TWENTY
AMPS IS REGISTERED
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY THOUSAND
VOLUNTEERS IN THE DHD SYSTEM
AND ON BOARDED OVER TWELVE
HUNDRED. HEALTH CORE CLINICAL
PROFESSIONALS FOR IMMEDIATE
DEPLOYMENT TODAY HEALTHCARE
PERSONNEL. OF FILLED OVER
THIRTY SIX HUNDRED SHIPS. BUT
WITH MATH FACILITIES JUST A
OVER NINETEEN RESPONSE. THE
REST WILL BE STAR. THE BILL
POOL RED ALSO SIR TO BOLSTER
THIS HELP BONTA MEDICAL WORSE
CORPS AND COME OUT MEMBERS
MEMBER SAYS HELP OR WERE READ.
JUST A PROGRAMS WERE APPROACH.
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH CORP
TRANSITION TO MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- OTHER SUCCESSES
BRIEFLY INCLUDE AT THE PHD
SYSTEM DISASTER HEALTHCARE
VOLUNTEERS IT'S THE MANAGES THE
PHD PROGRAM IN COLLABORATION
WITH LOCALLY ASSIGNED DH GAVE
MEDICAL RESERVE CORPS
COORDINATORS. THE SYSTEM IS
DESIGNED FOR LOCAL USED TO
SUPPORT LOCAL RESPONSES TO
EMERGENCIES ONE YEAR AGO THERE
WERE SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
REGISTERED VOLUNTEERS CURRENTLY
THERE ARE OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND VOLUNTEERS. REGISTERED
IN THE DHD SYSTEM DURING THE
COPA NINETEEN RESPONSE OVER
FOUR THOUSAND DHD AND MRC
VOLUNTEERS WERE DEPLOYED TO
SUPPORT LOCAL RESPONSE EFFORTS-
ACQUISITION OF ADDITIONAL
WAREHOUSE SPACE WAS A SUCCESS
FROM STUFF. BEFORE THE CODE
RESPONSE- YEP SAYS DMS DIVISION
RAN ALL OPERATIONS OUT OF ONE
THIRTY THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT
WAREHOUSE. FROM MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY THROUGH CURRENT. I AM
SAYS ALLIANCE. BUT TWO LARGE
WELL WAREHOUSES TO NOW SUPPORT
RESPONSE EFFORTS WITH A
COMBINED SPACE OF JUST OVER TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND SQUARE
FEET OF THIS ALLOWS US TO
ACCEPT HOUSE ORGANIZE AND
MAINTAIN OUR GREATLY EXPANDED
RESOURCES. AND ALSO SERVED AS
THE STATE REPORT REPOSITORY FOR
VENTILATORS AND ALL DURABLE
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT AS REQUIRED
BY OUR LOCALS AND FEDERAL
PARTNERS. THE AMBULANCE STRIKE
TEAM PROGRAM IS CERTAINLY
WORTHY OF ITS OWN CONVERSATION
SPENT ON IMMENSE SUCCESS IN
ATTRACTING PROGRAM PROVED
INVALUABLE DURING SEVERAL
ASPECTS OF CODE NINETEEN AND
THE TWENTY TWENTY WILDFIRE
RESPONSE. ACTIVITIES INCLUDED A
STATE WIDE SUPPORT FOR PATIENT
MOVEMENT- EVACUATION OF THE
DIAMOND PRINCESS CRUISE SHIP
SUPPORT TO IMPERIAL COUNTY.
DURING WHICH SHOT MORE THAN SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY PATIENTS WERE
MOVED OUT OF THAT COUNTY DURING
THE FIRST SEARCH THERE TO HELP
DECOMPRESS HOSPITALS- ALSO
EVACUATING MORE THAN FOUR
HUNDRED PATIENTS DURING THE
WILDFIRES. IN ALL OVER SIXTY
FIVE HUNDRED PATIENT TRANSPORTS
HAVE BEEN CONDUCTED STATEWIDE.
THROUGH THE STATE WIDE-
DISPOSITION CENTER AND
ANNALYNNE STRIKING CENTER
PROGRAMS ARE THERE BEEN MANY
LESSONS LEARNED REGARDING
PATIENT MOVEMENT AT THE END OF
THE STRIKING PROGRAM. IT'S A
PLANS TO CONTINUE LEADING THE
EVELYN STRIKE TEAM AND FIVE
THREE WORK REAL. WELL WHICH DID
KICK OFF JUST SHORTLY BEFORE
COVERED RESPONSE IS OBVIOUSLY
BEEN ON HOLD THROUGH THIS
RESPONSIBILITY THAT READY TO
RESTART THAT PROGRAM. AND TO
HELP BUILD ON LESSONS LEARNED
TO ADVANCE SCANDAL STRUCTURED
PROGRAM. AS MENTIONED PREVIOUS
GANDA'S TRACKING PROGRAM IS NOW
BEING UTILIZED TO. CREATE A-
VACCINATION DELIVERY PROGRAM
FOR THE HOME BALLOT- YES IS
IMPROVEMENT PLANS CURRENTLY AND
AFTER ACTION PLANS CURRENTLY
INCLUDE. UPDATING POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES FROM OUR LESSONS
LEARNED ALL THREE IN COVERT
RESPONSE AND FIRE RESPONSE. THE
PROTEAS TO ALLOCATION OF SCARCE
RESOURCES ENSURING EFFECTIVE
AND IMPROVE COMMUNICATIONS SAYS
COMMENTED EARLIER- AND PROCESS
FLOW FOR SITUATIONAL REPORTING
RESOURCE REQUESTING RESUPPLY
AND RESOURCE TRACKING. ENSURING
EFFECTIVE STATEWIDE PATIENT
MOVEMENTS ASSESSMENT OF
STAFFING NEEDS TO THE SIZE AND
DURATION OF THIS RESPONSE. AND
LASTLY IMPROVING THE EMS
HOSPITAL SYSTEM DATA INTERFACE
TO IMPROVE. S. I. E. THE STATE
AN ABSOLUTE TOWARDS DIRECT AND
REAL TIME DATA ACCESS SO THAT
WE CAN MORE CLOSELY TRACK THE
MOST IMPORTANT DATA SETS TO
CONTINUALLY ASSESS. THE QUOTE
HEALTH OF OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
I'M NOT HAVING REAL TIME DATA
WAS- A CHALLENGE DURING THE
CODE RESPONSE AND WE ALL WANT
TO PUSH TOWARDS A REAL TIME
DASHBOARDS AND READY ACCESS TO
DATASETS AS AS REQUIRED. ABOUT
A QUICKLY MY REPORTS OF PENDING
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU DR DUNCAN ALSO BELIEVE WE
HAVE A CRTE JOHNSON ON THE
LINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO ADD
ANYTHING FROM THEM SO BEFORE
GOING TO THE NEXT THE- PERSON.
OUR GOOD MORNING- MISTER CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS. I KNOW- DR DUNKIN I
THINK COVERED REALLY ALL THE
ASPECTS OF THAT I WOULD DOUBLE
GINGERLY. COMMENT ON HOWEVER I
AM HERE TO ASSIST WITH ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO NOW THE
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM A DOCTOR
THOMAS ARE GONE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH- DR THOMAS. OKAY GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING CHURCH
RODRIGUEZ AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
I WANT TO FIRST ACKNOWLEDGE THE
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICIALS AND
LOCAL FIRST RESPONDERS FOR
EVERYTHING THAT THEY'VE BEEN
DOING LOCALLY AT THE END OF THE
DAY ALL DISASTERS ARE LOCAL AND
THE WORK THAT THEY DO HAVE
REALLY I HAVE DONE A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT IN SOME OF THE THINGS
I'M GOING TO SAY. THAT I WILL
SUMMARIZE FOR YOU. FIVE I ALSO
COME FROM LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF MY
FIFTH MONTH SO BRING SOME OF MY
LOCAL PERSPECTIVE INTO WHAT I
REPORT TO YOU TODAY. I JUST
WANTED TO SHARE WITH YOU SOME
NUMBERS. SO AS OF YESTERDAY. IN
CALIFORNIA THERE WERE ONLY TWO
DEATHS THAT WERE REPORTED. THIS
IS THE LOWEST CAL THAT I AM
THIS IS THE LOWEST COUNT THAT I
CAN'T EVEN REMEMBER I HAD TO
DOUBLE CHECK JUST TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT WAS NOT AN ERROR. OUR
EFFECTIVE REPRODUCTIVE NUMBER
IS LESS THAN ONE IT'S ABOUT
POINT EIGHT EIGHT. OUR DAILY.
THE POINT 1% FOR THE MOST
RECENT WEEKS FOR WHICH OUR DATA
IS AVAILABLE FOR- THE UNITED
STATES- CALIFORNIA IN TERMS OF
ITS CASE RATE IS THE NUMBER ONE
HAS A LOOP HAS THE LOWEST CASE
RATE IN THE COUNTRY IN IN THE
MAINLAND. IT IS ONLY IN HIS
RANK TWO IF YOU INCLUDE HAWAII.
IN TERMS OF TEST POSITIVITY WE
HAVE THE LOWEST TEST POSITIVITY
IN THE UNITED STATES. IN TERMS
OF HOSPITAL ADMISSIONS WE ARE
RANKED NUMBER TEN. IN TERMS OF
IN TERMS OF DEATHS AMONG THE
TOP THE TEN MOST POPULOUS
STATES WE HAVE THE LOWEST DEATH
RATE. OVER THE PAST WEEKS AND
WHEN YOU LOOK AT CUMULATIVE
WHEN YOU LOOK AT CUBA- DEATH
RATE WE HAVE INTEREST IN TERMS
OF- BEING IN TERMS OF- HAVING
TO THE LOWER NUMBER WE WOULD BE
TWENTY NINTH MEANING THAT- WE
HAVE AMONG THE LOWEST
CUMULATIVE DEATH RATES. IN THE
COUNTRY AND THAT'S REMARKABLE
CONSIDERING THAT CALIFORNIA WAS
ONE OF THE FIRST AREAS WHERE CO
THAT ENTERED AN IMPACT IT
IMPACTED IN IMPACTED BOTH THE
WEST COAST AND EAST COAST FIRST.
IN TERMS OF ACTING UPDATE THE
OPERATING HEARD SOME OF THE
NUMBERS OVER A THIRTY POINT
FIVE MILLION DOSES HAVE BEEN
ADMINISTERED. WE HAVE TWELVE
POINT SIX MILLION CALIFORNIANS
WHO ARE FULLY VACCINATED THAT
FORTY POINT FOUR. WE HAVE SIX
POINT TWO MILLION VACCINES ARE
ADMINISTERED IN DEBT WHETHER WE
CALL THE HEALTHY PLACES INDEX
QUARTILE ONE WHICH I'LL EXPLAIN
IN AND IN A MOMENT. OVER 60% OF
OUR POPULATION HAS RECEIVED
OVER ONE DOSE. OF PERSONS OVER
SIXTY FIVE YEARS OLD 75% HAVE
RECEIVED. MORE THAN ONE DOSE
AND SIXTY ONE OF THEM OF SIXTY
FIVE AND OLDER ARE FULLY
VACCINATED. THOSE ARE
INCREDIBLE NUMBERS
UNFORTUNATELY PLEASE CONTINUE
TO HAVE VACCINE INEQUITIES THE
HEALTHY PLACES INDEX WHICH HAS
BEEN THE PRIMARY OUT ABOUT WAY
THAT WE'VE BEEN A CATEGORIZING
LOOKING AT ACROSS CALIFORNIA
LOOKING BOTH THE CENSUS TRACTS
IN ZIP CODES LOWER INCOME AREAS
AND HIGHER INCOME AREAS PLACES
THAT ARE ARE ARE LEFT RESOURCE
IN PLACES WHERE PERSONS OF
COLOR- CONCENTRATE. CURRENTLY
IN THE QUEUE ONE QUARTILE WHICH
IS THE LEAST ADVANTAGED THE
LOWEST INCOME R. O. ONLY 47%
HAVE RECEIVED AT LEAST ONE DOSE
47% SOUNDS GOOD AND WE SHOULD
BE WE SHOULD BE PROUD THAT
WE'VE ACHIEVED 47% HOWEVER IN
OUR HIGHEST INCOME QUARTILE THE
MOST ADVANTAGE ADVANTAGE IT'S
SEVENTY ONE PERCENT. AND THAT'S
THE IN EQUITY IN THAT THE GAP
THAT WE REALLY WE REALLY NEED
TO CLIP WE WOULD REALLY NEED TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU FOR THE THAT
WE BEEN USING OUR TO LEAD WITH
SCIENCE COMPASSION EQUITY. TO
INTERRUPT TRANSMISSION OVERALL
TRANSMISSION ANYWHERE AND THE
IMPACT IN THE MOST THE MOST LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES ANY
TRANSMISSION THAT HAPPENS WE
KNOW THAT IS THE ESSENTIAL THE
CENTRAL WORKERS HAVE BECOME
INFECTED THEY BRING IT BACK
INTO THEIR HOUSEHOLDS. WHICH
TEND TO BE OVER COURT
OVERCROWDED AND TRANSMISSION IS
VERY IS VERY HIGH. AND THEN OF
COURSE WE ALSO WANT TO
PRIORITIZE UP FOCUSING ON THE
HIGHEST IMPACT COMMUNITIES. THE
WAY THAT WE HAVE FOCUS ARE
FAXING PROGRAMS HAS BEEN WITH
THREE KEY PRINCIPLES SAFETY.
EQUITY AND TRANSPARENCY. SO I
HAD MENTIONED THAT THE H. B. I.
COURT DATES BACK QUARTILES HAVE
BEEN HAVE BEEN USE CONSISTENTLY
WE USE THAT DURING OUR OUR
BLUEPRINT TO INCENTIVIZE TO
INCENTIVIZE TESTING AND GETTING
FOCUSED ON THE LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND THEN WE USE
THAT FOR A VACCINE EQUITY MET
UP AT METRIC WHICH IS ZIP CODE
BATES THE REASON WHY WE USE THE
ZIP CODES BASED MASSIVE METHOD
BECAUSE MOST PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
WHERE THE CENSUS TRACK IS THAT
NOT EVERYBODY WILL GIVE YOU
THEIR ADDRESS BUT PEOPLE ARE
USUALLY WILLING TO GIVE YOU THE
ZIP CODE. SO THERE WAS. A
QUESTION EARLIER ABOUT HOW DO
WE KNOW THAT WE KNOW IT- IF
SOMEBODY- YOUR ACCOUNT BEEN
BACK. AND SO THAT THAT'S A THAT
WAS AN IMPORTANT ARE TERM OF
OUR DAY STRATEGY TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE USE THE ZIP CODE BASIS
THAT WILL ALL SEACM K. RATE BY
THE DIFF TACK. BUT ALSO A LOT
TOWN SAN DIEGO WHO IN THEIR
ACCOUNT HAVE BEEN ACROSS THIS.
THE OTHER POINT THINK ABOUT OUR
FAX. THIS WAS. BOB ARE PER.
STRATEGY AND WE DO IT HAVE IT
DURING THE HIGH. SEARCH WHEN
THE HIGH. WITH THE HIGHEST
SEARCH FOR HAPPENING LET ME FOR
OF ALL SIR SAYING THAT WE KNOW
THE- COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THOSE
THAT MOST AND- PUTTING THOSE.
WERE OF WITH THE GROUP WAS MOST
IMPACT MEDINA REPRESENT THIRTY
NINE. OF THE POP. IN CALIFORNIA
THEY REPRESENTED 60% OF THE
CASES. AND 46% OF THE DEATH.
80% OF THE DEATHS OCCURRED IN
PAID PEOPLE OVER SIXTY FIVE.
THAT MEANS THAT. THE IN THE HOT
IN THE HOSPITAL DURING THE
SEARCH THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
MOSTLY IMPACTED WHO WERE IN THE
HOSPITAL I SEE YOU. AND WE'RE
DYING. WERE PEOPLE OF PEOPLE OF.
COLOR PRIMARILY LATINO. AND
WE'RE REAL IS THAT WE NEED TO
SHOW TO IN A BASED. BECAUSE WE
HAD TO WHAT WE HAVE TO HAVE A
THIRD STRATEGY THAT WAS SIMPLE
TO IMPLEMENT AND THAT COULD BE
IMPLEMENTED WITH SPEED THE IDEA
WAS IS THAT. BURGO WE KNOW
THAT. THE OLDER OLDER FOLKS ARE
THE ONES THERE AND THEN UP IN
THE HOSPITAL AND DYING AS OUR
FAXING STRATEGY HOW TO PAY THAT
BY PRIORITIZING. BY
PRIORITIZING AGE THEN WE
PRIORITIZE MEDICAL CONDITIONS
AND THEN PERSONS WITH
DISABILITY AND THE LAST
IMPORTANT PILLAR OF THE
STRATEGY IS THE CONCENTRATOR
OUT REACH AN ALLOCATION AND OUR
EFFORTS. IN THE LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES QUARTILES ONE INTO
SO THE COMBINATION OF AGE
MEDICAL CONDITION DISABILITY
AND THEN. AND THEN-
CONCENTRATING IN. THE AREAS
THAT ARE THAT ARE MOST IMPACTED.
SO WHEN YOU THE- OVERALL
OVERALL STRATEGY THERE WERE
THERE WERE FIVE MAJOR AIR FIVE
MAJOR AREAS THAT- THAT. THE
WHAT'S CALLED THE THAT BOTH THE
STATE AND THE T. PAY THE THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATOR FOCUSED ON
WAS ALLOCATIONS OF 40% THE
VACCINES. THAT INITIALLY GOING
TO THE H. P. I. ONE QUARTILE
THE- THAT THE LOWEST INCOME.
DEVELOPING A NETWORK OF
PROVIDERS ACROSS THE STATE. AND
I DO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE OUR
DOCTOR- AMY SISKIND WHO
MENTIONED THE I. YAHOO BENCHES-
THE VFC PROGRAM FOR CHILDHOOD
VACCINATIONS. AND THAT THAT
PROGRAM WILL BE IMPLEMENTED
WITHOUT NEEDING TO BE ENROLLED
IN THE T. PH. D.'S VACCINE
PROVIDERS ALREADY KNOW HOW TO
FAXING TO VACCINATE CHILDREN.
HAVE AS ITS AS THE CHILDHOOD
VACCINES BECOME AVAILABLE
THEY'RE ALREADY IN PLACE
THEY'RE ALREADY CONNECTED TO
OUR IMMUNIZATION REGISTRY. DATA
WE'RE GOING TO PROVIDE ALL THE
SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE DATE THAT WE GET
AS MANY KIDS VACCINATED. AS
FAST AS POSSIBLE. THIRTY AREAS
WORKING WITH COMMUNITY PARTNERS.
THE AREA IS WITH IS WITH DATA.
AND DATA WAS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE.
HISTORICALLY WE EVEN THOUGH WE
HAVE GOT A VACCINE REGISTRY FOR
MANY YEARS IT WAS NOT AT THE
LEVEL OF. PREPAREDNESS THAT
WOULD BE REQUIRED FOR US TO
REALLY HAVE THE QUALITY OF DATA
SO THAT WE CAN REALLY TRACK
METRICS. I KNOW EXACTLY WHO'S
GETTING VACCINATED WHERE THEY
LIVE AND COLLECTING SUFFICIENT
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION SO THAT
WE CAN ACTUALLY WE CAN ACTUALLY
FOCUS ON EQUITY. SO THAT WE CAN
LOOK AT THE DISPARITIES I
MENTIONED TO YOU EARLIER ARE
POSSIBLE WE COULD SEE THE
DISPARITIES BECAUSE OF A QUOTE
THE QUOTE DATA. QUALITY
IMPROVED AND OF ALL SEVERAL
STATEWIDE DATA SYSTEMS
INCLUDING OUR IMMUNIZATION
REGISTRY OUR INVENTORY SYSTEM
CALL CA FAX MY TURN THAT HAD A
COMPONENT WHERE ANYBODY CAN LOG
IN INTO MY TURN REGISTER- AND
GET AN APPOINTMENT AS WELL AS
MY TURN CLINIC SO. PEOPLE COULD
RUN A CLINIC. A TURN THAT DATA
WE ALSO WORK CLOSELY WITH
RESEARCHERS AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA AT STANFORD. WHO
TOOK ALL THE ALL THE ALL THE WE
KNEW ABOUT THE VIRUS ALTHOUGH
WE KNEW ABOUT THE DEMOGRAPHICS
AND HELPED US TO DEVELOP A
STRATEGY. OF HOW WE CAN END
THIS PANDEMIC AS FAST AS
POSSIBLE AND THE FASTEST WAY OF
ENDING THIS PANDEMIC IS BY
FOCUSING ON THE MOST IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES. THAT'S WHERE
TRANSMISSIONS HAPPENING MOST BY
AND THAT'S THE THAT THE FASTEST
ROUTE INCIDENT THAT THE THOUGHT
LEADING WITH SCIENCE WE CAN
TELL THE WHOLE STATE HOPE. THAT
BY FOCUSING ON THESE
COMMUNITIES EVERYBODY BENEFITS.
PUBLIC EDUCATION WE HAVE
VACCINATE ALL FIFTY A CAMPAIGN
DURING A TREMENDOUS FORMATIVE
RESEARCH- FOR EXAMPLE ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT- OUR
RESEARCHERS FOUND IN LOOKING AT
PEOPLE WHO ARE INTERESTED IN
GETTING VACCINATED WHEN YOU
LOOK AT LATINOS WITH A YEAR.
SPANISH DOMINANT FOR BILINGUAL
FLASH ENGLISH IT TURNS OUT THAT
LATINOS THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THEM ARE WILLING TO GET
VACCINATED. SO REALLY. IT IS
PRIMARILY AN ISSUE OF ACCESS.
OPPOSITE ISSUE OF OUTREACH. OF
AND THEN THE OTHER GROUP WHERE
THERE IS IT THERE IS THERE'S
LESS WILLINGNESS TO GET
VACCINATED AND THAT'S IN THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY SO
THERE'S LIKE A CONTRAST THERE
WERE WE HAVE TO DO MORE WORK TO
BUILD TRUST WITH THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY. WE'RE IT
WE'RE IMPLEMENTING A NEW
VACCINE EQUITY PLAN THE RIGHT
NOW'S GONNA BE FOCUSING ON
THIRTEEN COUNTIES. WHERE WE'RE
GONNA TRY TO GET TAT THE GOAL
IS TO GET 75% COVERAGE OF IN
THE EIGHT IN THE QUARTILE ONE
THE LOWEST INCOME QUARTILE BY
JUNE FIFTEENTH A LOT OF WORK
AHEAD- THAT'S OUR GOAL LOOK
WE'RE GONNA SEE YOU EVER GONNA
BE ABLE TO REACH IT A LOT OF
WORK HAPPENING AROUND THAT. AND
AT THIS POINT IT'S REALLY ABOUT
GETTING HYPER LOCAL I'LL JUST
GIVING EXAMPLES OF TWO WEEKS
AGO I WENT TO VISIT IN THE
NATION IN THE MISSION DISTRICT-
I WENT TO GO VISIT THAT WAS
HAPPENING- HOW THEY WERE DOING
OUR REGION IN THE LATINO
COMMUNITY SO I WENT TO ST
PETER'S CHURCH. IN THE CHURCH
THE POINT WHERE THEY HAVE
SPANISH MASS THE PRIEST WOULD
ASK PEOPLE HOW MANY OF YOU HAVE
BEEN VACCINATED HOW MANY DO YOU
HAVE DROPPED IT HOW MAY BE OF
THE VACCINATED THEN AND THEN
THE PRIEST WILL TELL THAT WELL.
FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT HAVEN'T
BEEN VACCINATED RIGHT AFTER
CHURCH WE HAVE A TEAM OF PEOPLE
OUT OUTSIDE THE DOORS SITTING
THERE FOR WHAT CAN GET TO
REGISTER. RIGHT AWAY TO GET TO
GET VACCINATED. AND SO THAT A
WE HAVE STOPPED THAT FROM PAUL.
HEALTH ALSO COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
AS A WORKING WITH THE FAITH
BASED COMMUNITY WAS REALLY
CRITICAL THEN I JUST WALKED OUT
OF TWENTY FOUR THE MISSION
WHERE THEY HAVE THE VACCINATION
SITE. AND THE VACCINATION SIDE
OF ONE SIDE OF THE STREET WHERE
THEY DID VACCINATIONS ON THE
OTHER SIDE STREET THEY DID
TESTING. IT'S A IT'S A
TRANSPORTATION HUB WERE A LOT
OF PEOPLE. BECAUSE YOU USED TO
TAKE OUT THE SUBWAY. AND THE
BUSES OUR MISSION STREET. AND
SO WHEN YOU GET WHEN YOU WOULD
GO THERE PEOPLE WOULD ACTUALLY
FEEL VERY AT HOME- THEY WOULD
HAVE MUSIC. THEY MADE THE PLACE
VERY WELCOMING WHERE PEOPLE
WERE SITTING DOWN- AFTER THEY
RECEIVE THE VACCINE BECAUSE YOU
HAVE A FIFTEEN MINUTE
OBSERVATION PERIOD. THEY WOULD
COME AND TALK TO THEM FIND OUT
HOW ARE THINGS GOING AT HOME
HOW CAN WE SUPPORT YOU. IS
THERE ANYBODY AT HOME THAT'S
NOT VACCINATED- AND REALLY
RECOGNIZING THAT THE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS THAT ARE GETTING BACK
VACCINATED ARE THE BEST
AMBASSADORS. ARE THE BEST
AMBASSADORS. FOR GETTING
VACCINATED RIGHT BECAUSE THEY
CAN GO HOME AND BRING PEOPLE
BRING PEOPLE BACK. BUT THE
OTHER THING IS ACTUALLY I WE
HAVE ONE OF OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. WAS TELLING US HOW
THEY HAD A CAMPAIGN WHERE THEY
JUST WENT DOOR TO DOOR DOWN THE
COMMERCIAL CORRIDORS. INTO
EVERY SINGLE BUSINESS. AND SAID AND TALK TO THE WORKERS ARE
YOU IF YOU'RE NOT VACCINATED.
WE'RE HERE TO GET YOU WE'RE
HERE TO GET YOUR REGISTER TO
GET YOU CONNECTED- THINGS LIKE
PHONE BANKS YOU'LL BE HEARING
MORE IN THE IN THE COMING WEEKS
ABOUT THE EFFORTS THAT.
CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO BE DOING
INCLUDING PHONE BANKS. OF DOOR
KNOCKING CAMPAIGNS WORKING WITH
THAT FAITH BASED ORGANIZATIONS-
OF LOCAL GRANTS FOR COMMUNITIES
YOU ALREADY HEARD. FROM MS THAT
ABOUT THAT. AT HOME VACCINATION
PROGRAM AND THERE IS ALSO A
FREE. A FREE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM. SO I DO WANNA SAY
TERMS OF. LESSONS YOU KNOW IT'S
A LOT OF A LOT OF FOLKS CAN
SAVE A LOT OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE HAVE- WE KNEW WE WERE
GOING TO HAVE THEM THE
INEQUITIES EXISTED- BEFORE
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC. THE PET
THAT MAKE JUST. REVEALED CAN
AMPLIFY THE INEQUITIES THAT WE
HAVE AND WE JUST HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE IS THAT WE HAVE TO
TAKE EVERYTHING THAT WE KNOW
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE GO WE GO
BACK AND FIX AS MUCH AS WE CAN.
AND THEN THE OTHER CHALLENGE IS
GOING TO BE REALLY SORT OF
BALANCING HOW WE WORK WITH THE
LOCALS AND THE LOCALS ARE
REALLY ARE REALLY THE BEST THAT
UNDERSTANDING THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND REALLY DOING THAT LAST MILE
OF ACTUALLY GETTING. GETTING A
VACCINE VACCINES INTO
COMMUNITIES THEY THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT BETTER THAN
ANYBODY ELSE THE STATE ON THE
OTHER HAND HOW SOME
CAPABILITIES BECAUSE WE CAN
WORK ACROSS COUNTIES WE CAN
MOVE ASSETS ACROSS THE STATE WE
CAN SUPPORT THEM WE CAN WORK A
LARGE DATA SYSTEMS. THAT CAN
REALLY HELP HELP HELP GUIDE
THEM BUT ALSO HELPS GUIDE THE
STATE EVERY PRIORITIZE
RESOURCES AS THINGS EVOLVE SO I
JUST FINDING THAT RIGHT BALANCE
AND REALLY WORKING ON THAT
PARTNERSHIP- I THINK IT'S
REALLY REALLY REALLY CRITICAL I
WANT TO AGAIN THANK- THE CHAIR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THANK ALL THE
LOCAL FOR ALL THE AMAZING WORK
THAT YOU DO AND- RIGHT YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW IS IN A
GOOD PLACE SO KEEP YOUR FINGERS
CROSSED. WE HAVE TO STAY AHEAD
OF THE VARIANCE AND- YOU KNOW
THIS IS HOW WE'RE GOING TO
DEFEAT THE PANDEMIC SO IT'S
REALLY IT REALLY IS IT'S A IT'S
A TEAM EFFORT IT'S ALL STATE
EFFORT. YES I JUST WANT TO
EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE FOR TO
EVERYBODY FOR ALL THAT YOU DO.
ALL SUPPORT THAT YOU GIVE US
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DOT PURSE
THAT AND FINALLY. HERE FROM OUR
LAST- BUT IT'S BEEN WE HAVE
DIRECTOR MARKED OVERDUE CHU
FROM THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES- MARK ARE
YOU THERE. BROWN'S ALL RIGHT
WELL GOOD MORNING THANKS A-
ZURCHER ARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- THANKS AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS THE
IMPORTANCE OF MANAGING THE
STATE'S COVERT RESPONSE IN A
MANNER THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH
CALIFORNIA'S VALUES AT OF
EQUITY. HERE IS A STATE AGENCY
THAT THE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
COORDINATING THE OVERALL
STATE'S RESPONSE TO DISASTERS
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S MUCH THAT WE
COULD TALK ABOUT ABOUT THE
OPERATIONS THAT SO MANY
OPERATIONS THAT WERE INVOLVED
WITH THE CORPORATE RESPONSE AND
MANY OTHERS YEAH WALL BOB WE'RE
DEALING WITH COVERT BUT TODAY.
I WANT I'M GONNA FOCUS ON THE
ROLE OF CALLAWAY GAS IN THE
STATE'S EFFORTS TO VACCINATE
CALIFORNIA'S. MOST AT RISK
COMMUNITIES. AS A STATE HAVE
BEEN- WE HAVE MUCH TO BE PROUD
UP WE IMPLEMENTED INNOVATIVE
FIRST IN THE NATION PROGRAMS TO
MITIGATE THE PANDEMICS OF
FACTS. ON THE STATE'S MOST
DISPROPORTIONATELY COBIT
NINETEEN IMPACTED COMMUNITIES.
WE MUST COMMIT OURSELVES TO
CONTINUOUSLY IMPROVING OUR
PROGRAMS AND IDENTIFY AND
IDENTIFY EVEN MORE
OPPORTUNITIES TO BETTER SERVE
THEM. AS A STATE AS WE LEARN
MORE FROM THE OUTCOMES OF THIS
PARTICULAR EVENT. AS OF MAY
SECOND TWENTY TWENTY ONE OF THE
STATE HAD A CUMULATIVE TOTAL OF
OVER THREE POINT SIX MILLION
PROGRAM RELATED CASES AND
FORTUNATELY OVER SIXTY THOUSAND.
EIGHT CALORIES HOWEVER TODAY WE
HAVE A POSITIVITY RATE OF ONE
POINT ONE WHICH REPRESENTS THE
LOWEST IN THE NATION. AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN CELEBRATE.
EQUITY IS AT THE CORE OF THE
STATE'S COVERT RESPONSE. FULLY
INTEGRATING EQUITY PLANNING
PRINCIPLES IT ALL PHASES OF
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT HELPS
EMERGENCY MANAGERS BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS OF THE
WHOLE OF COMMUNITY AND HOW TO
CREATE PROGRAMS POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES. THAT FOR FILL THOSE
NEEDS. EARLY IN THIS OF AT
HELLO YES ESTABLISHED WELL OVER
TWENTY TASK FORCES WHICH
INCLUDED EXPERTS FROM VARIOUS
STATE AGENCIES TO DEVELOP
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS AND
GUIDANCE ON ALL ASPECTS OF
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT FOR THIS
EVENT. WELL ACCURATE WELL
EQUITY WAS CERTAINLY A KEY
PRIORITY FOR ALL. TRUE PASSED
FORCES STAND OUT CONSIDERABLY
AND OUR COMMITMENT. TO AN
EQUITABLE RESPONSE TO THIS
VIRUS. THE CENTRAL VALLEY
PASSPORTS IN COORDINATION WITH
LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS IDENTIFY
STRATEGIES TO REDUCE HEALTHCARE
IMPACTS. TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY
REGION WITH AN EMPHASIS ON
PREVENTION AND REDUCTION OF
COVERT NINETEEN TRANSMISSION.
AND A WHOLE SECTOR APPROACH.
AND THE VACCINE TASK FORCE
WHICH CONVENE TO INSURE
CALIFORNIA HAS COMPREHENSIVE
EQUITABLE ACCESS. TO EDUCATION
AROUND COVERT NINETEEN
VACCINATION WITH AN EMPHASIS ON
SAFETY AND- EFFICIENCY. THE
NETWORK OF TASK FORCES WERE KEY
IN DEVELOPING MANY OF THE
PROGRAMS FOR SUPPORT G. SECTORS
OF OUR COMMUNITIES THERE ARE
SOME KEY EXAMPLES. PROJECT ROOM
HE- THE FIRST SUCH PROGRAM IN
THE NATION TO SECURE FEMA
APPROVAL PROVIDE SAFE ISOLATION
CAPACITY FOR TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS OUR GOAL REQUIRE
FIFTEEN THOUSAND ROOMS TO SERVE
THIS COMMUNITY WAS REACHED ON
MAY ELEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY.
GREAT PLATES IS A FEEDING
PROGRAM AIMED TOWARD SENIORS
AND ADULTS AT HIGH RISK FROM
KROGER NINETEEN. URGES THEM TO
REMAIN AT HOME AND STAY HEALTHY
BY DELIVERING THREE NUTRITIOUS
MEALS A DAY. TODAY IT HAS
SERVED OVER THIRTY TWO MILLION
MEALS. HOUSING FOR THE HARVEST
PROVIDES TEMPORARY EMERGENCY
NON CONGREGATE SHELTER FOR
FARMWORKERS UP A PLACE FOR SELF
ISOLATE ISOLATION KEEPING THEIR
FAMILIES EVER GREATER COMMUNITY
SAFE. AS A CENTRAL WORKERS.
HOTEL FOR HEALTH CARE WORKERS
HE WAS CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
WORKERS AND OTHER PUBLIC SAFETY
PERSONNEL SAFE AND HEALTHY BY
REDUCING THE SPREAD OF THE
COVER NINETEENTH VIRUS THROUGH
FREE OR DISCOUNTED HOTEL ROOMS
TO HEALTHCARE WORKERS OR PUBLIC
SAFETY WORKERS WHO GIVE
CRITICAL CARE THE COVER
NINETEEN PATIENTS SO THEY DO
NOT BRING HOME. THE VIRUS FOR
THEIR HOUSEHOLD. VACCINATION
SITES A SIGNIFICANT DEVELOPMENT
IN CALIFORNIA'S RESPONSE TO THE
PAD THAT MAKE. WAS IN FEBRUARY
OF THIS YEAR WHEN THE GOVERNOR
AND THE FIGHTING HERE SAID
MINISTRATION ANNOUNCED A FIRST
OF ITS KIND PARTNERSHIP TO
BRING LIFESAVING VACCINES TO
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
THROUGH THIS PROGRAM OAKLAND
AND LOS ANGELES WERE CHOSEN AND
WORK JOINTLY OPERATED BY- YES
AND FEMALE. TO GIVE YOU A SENSE
OF THE SCALE OF THIS OPERATION
THERE ARE OVER TWO THOUSAND
STAFF FROM OVER FIFTY FIVE
DIFFERENT STATE AND FEDERAL
AGENCIES. AND PRIVATE SECTOR
DEDICATED TO THIS EFFORT
WORKING ON THE GROUND AT THE
SITE THE STATE AND FEDERAL
SITES. TO BETTER SERVE THE
COMMUNITY. AT THE AMPLIFY OUR
EQUITY. REQUIREMENTS WE
DESIGNED IT IMPLEMENTED A
MOBILE VACCINATION CLINIC
PROGRAM. IN EACH OF THESE
LOCATIONS. BEYOND THE FIXED
SITE. AND MOBILE UNITS WOULD GO
OUT AND PENETRATE INTO THE
COMMUNITY INTO THOSE AREAS THAT
WERE MOST UNDERSERVED- AND AS
WE'LL DISCUSS LATER. TO BE VERY
IMPACTFUL THE COMMUNITIES.
THESE TWO SITES ONE OF THE
OAKLAND COLISEUM. EVERYONE AT
THE CAL STATE UNIVERSITY LA
AWKWARD WHERE A DENTURE TGP
LOCATED IN LOS ANGELES IN EAST
LA. EVERY AREAS WHERE WE SAW
HIGH CONCENTRATIONS OF PROGRAM
RELATED IMPACT AT ANY FOR
OAKLAND ARE BOTH UNDER SERVED
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES.
IN TOTAL AS OF APRIL TWELFTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE HAVE
ADMINISTERED OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
AND TWENTY THOUSAND
VACCINATIONS TOTAL AT BOTH MASS
VACCINATION SITES. A HUNDRED
AND THREE THOUSAND OF THOSE
VACCINATIONS OR THROUGH THE
MOBILE UNITS. THE COMMUNITY
VACCINATION CENTERS INCLUDED IN
PERSON INTERPRETATION FOR SIX
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES SPANISH
VIETNAMESE KOREAN. HI ALL
MANDARIN AND CANTONESE. ON SITE
AS WELL AS PROVIDED IN PERSON
A. S. L. INTERPRETATION. AND
THE COMMITTEE VACCINATION
CENTERS HAVE DEDICATED PARA
TRANSIT LINES TO IMPROVE
EFFICIENCY. OF THEIR SERVICE
WITHOUT MUCH AGREEMENTS WITH
THE PARA TRANSIT PROVIDER FOR
FREE SERVICE TO AND FROM THE
HOME OF AN INDIVIDUAL WITH
APPOINTMENTS WE UTILIZE
SHUTTLES THAT FERRY BACK AND
FORTH BUT LOCAL BOSTON TRADE
SITES. IN THE SURROUNDING AREA.
OVERALL THE MOBILE UNITS
PROVIDED FIVE HUNDRED THREE
THOUSAND VACCINATIONS. OF THESE
520-004-0018 WARD MINISTERED
ALAMEDA COUNTY. AND FIFTY ONE
THOUSAND IF FORWARD MISSTATED
LOS ANGELES. THE SUCCESS OF THE
MOBILE UNITS IS A TESTAMENT TO
THE RELATIONSHIPS WE BUILD WITH
THE TRUSTED PARTNERS IN THE
COMMUNITY. BE STRONG
RELATIONSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND FAITH
BASED ORGANIZATIONS ALAMEDA
PUBLIC HEALTH CONTRA COSTA
PUBLIC HEALTH LOS ANGELES
COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH BUT THE
LOS ANGELES MAYOR'S OFFICE. AND
THE LOS ANGELES FIRE DEPARTMENT
THE SCHEDULE THE MOBILE SITES
IN. IN LOCATIONS OF GREATEST
NEED. WE IDENTIFY THE AREAS OF
GREATEST NEED BY LOOKING AT TWO
MEASURES IMMUNITIES IN THE
LOWEST QUARTILE OF HEALTHY
PLACE INDEX. ADMITTED WITH THE
LOWEST VACCINATION RATE EACH
MOBILE CLINIC. AS A HOST
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
THAT WORKS WITH THE OTHER
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION IN
THE VICINITY TO DO OUTREACH.
LEADER TRUSTED COMMUNITY VOICES
THAT CAN REACH COMMITTEE
MEMBERS IN A WAY THAT WE JUST
COULDN'T. IT WAS OUR JOB TO
BACK THEM UP. WE MADE REAL TIME
CHANGES ON A DAY TO DAY BASIS
AT THE MOBILE SITE. TO MEET THE
UNIQUE NEEDS OF EACH COMMUNITY
FOR EXAMPLE IF WE FOUND THAT
THERE WAS MORE. HOW TO LOG
SPEAKERS AT ONE SITE FOR MORE
WHEELCHAIRS WERE NEEDED AT
ANOTHER RESPONDED IT REAL TIME
TO MEET THOSE NEEDS. DURING THE
EIGHT WEEK- YES FEMA MISSION WE
PARTNERED WITH FORTY ONE
ORGANIZATIONS. THAT SERVE. AS
THE COMMUNITY LEAD. OUR MOBILE
UNITS NINE CBO'S AT ELEVEN FBOS
ALAMEDA AND FIFTEEN CBO IS. AT
SIX FBOS IN LOS ANGELES. OF
THOSE SERVED AT THE MOBILE
CLINICS IN OAKLAND AS OF APRIL
TWELFTH TWENTY TO. TWENTY ONE
ALMOST 26% IDENTIFIED. AS
LATICS. OVER 20% OF BLACK
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND OVER 23%
OF ASIAN. AND LOS ANGELES OVER
51% OF THOSE VACCINATED MOBILE
SITES IDENTIFIED AS LATICS.
ALMOST 19% WERE BLACK AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND OVER 5% WERE ASIAN.
SO NOW I LIKE TO PUT UP A CHART
TO GIVE YOU SOME CONTEXT AS TO
THE IMPACT. OF THE- OF THE
MOBILE CLINICS AND THE WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING THIS IS
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA. THAT IS
SHOWING THE- MOBILE VACCINATION
KEEP FAX. AND YOUCAN SEE- FROM
THE DEMOGRAPHIC DATA BAR IN LOS
ANGELES AND OAKLAND. ARE THE
PERCENTAGES OF- OF PENETRATION
INTO THE- VARIOUS DEMOGRAPHIC.
CHAPTERS AND IT IT REALLY OUR
FOCUS WAS TO CONTINUALLY WORK
TO- YOU KNOW REACH THESE.
EQUITY NUMBERS HE'S EQUITY
METRICS THE TEAM I DON'T WE
ASIN FEMA AND ALL OF OUR
PARTNERS CBO'S AND FBOS REALLY
FOCUSED TO TRY APPLE FIVE THE
ABILITY TO GET SHOTS IN ARMS
INTO THESE COMMUNITIES IN MANY
WAYS THESE MOBILE CLINICS ROCK
THE SHOTS TO THEM. THIS WAS AN
EFFORT OF GOING TO THEM. AT
PLACE OF TRUSTED AREA. CHURCHES
CLINICS AND OTHER PLACES WHERE
THEY FELT MOST COMFORTABLE- TO
BE ABLE TO GET THE SHOT YOU CAN
SEE BY THOSE NUMBERS. ARE WHERE
WHERE THINGS ARE HELLO LOOK
LIKE. SO I'LL SHOW YOU KNOW
WHAT HEATMAP UP AND GO TO NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. IT DEMONSTRATES-
OUR. OKAY SO THESE ARE THESE
ARE HEATMAPS THIS IS LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND- THIS IS ON
A THREE FIVE- AS UNDERSERVED
POPULATION RISK ANALYSIS AND
YOU COULD SEE ARE IN THE IN
THE- TRIANGLE THERE ON THE LEFT
THE HIGH RISK HIGH VACCINATION
LOW RISK LOW VACCINATION LOW
RISK HIGH VACCINATION BY COLORS
AND YOU CAN SEE. IF YOU IF YOU
LOOK IN THE CENTER PART OF
THAT- HEATMAP YOU SEE A LOT OF
READ A LOT OF HIGH RISK LOW
VACCINATION THIS IS EAST LOS
ANGELES THE SOUTH CENTRAL LOS
ANGELES- AREAS WHERE WE- E
KNOW WE'RE SETTING UP MOBILE
CLINICS- WE HAD OUR FIX
LOCATION AT CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY LA AND THIS WAS THAT
REPRESENTING- WE'RE FOR THE
LITTLE GREEN DOTS ARE WHERE WE
WERE PUTTING. OUR MOBILE
CLINICS WORKING WITH CBO'S
FBOS- AND THIS WS A VERY
CONCERNING VERY INTENSE EFFORTS
OF OUTREACH OF BEING ABLE TO
BUILD TRUST IN THE COMMUNITY
ARE BEING ABLE TO ARTICULATE
THE IMPORTANCE OF GETTING THE
VACCINE AND THIS WAS WORKING
WITH OUR PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICES
THIS IS WORKING WITH OUR
ELECTED OFFICIALS- AND OTHER
TRUSTED SOURCES ARE PASTORS AND
OTHER KEY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY THAT WERE TRUSTED TO
BE ABLE TO HELP US AT THE SITES
UP SO. THIS WAS ONE THREE FIVE
GOES NEXT LIGHT. WE'LL SEE THAT-
WE ARE- THESE ARE EIGHT P. I. I
WILL TO IN SERIOUS YOU'LL SEE
BUY THREE FOR. TEN DAYS LATER.
YOU START TO SEE A REDUCTION IN
THE- BOB OUT OF RED SO YOU'RE
NOW MOVE- FROM THE HIGHER LOW
VACCINATION. UPWARDS TOWARDS
THE HIGHER RISK HIGHER
VACCINATION. BECAUSE WE'RE
STARTING TO SEE IF YOU GOT MORE
DARKER GREEN. IN THAT AREA NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. SO ON THREE
TWENTY FOUR- AGAIN NOW THINGS
ARE LOOKING EVEN MORE DIFFERENT
THIS IS WHERE WE'RE STARTING TO
SEE HOW YOU SEE ALMOST NO RAD-
NOW AND- AGAIN YOU'RE IN THAT
MIDDLE ZONE BETWEEN. OUR LOW
VACCINATION HIGH VACCINATION-
AT STILL IN THE HIGH RISK. AREA
OF THE COUNTY NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
THREE THIRTY M. R. LA AGAIN
NOW- JUST THE YOU CAN SEE A
CONTINUED TO MAKE MOVEMENT
GETTING TOWARDS MORE TO THE
GREEN OF THE HIGH RISK HIGH
VACCINATION AND IN SOME AREAS
GETTING INTO THE LOW RISK HIGH
VACCINATION. NEXT LIVE WITH.
RIGHT NOW WE ARE IN ALMOST ALL
HIGH RISK HIGH VACCINATION. AND
LOOKING VERY VERY POSITIVE NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. AND THEN OUT FOR
THIRTEEN- REALLY YOU'RE NOW
ALL- IN GREEN- HIGHLY
VACCINATED- AND YOU WE SEE
WE'RE MAKING EXTREME AT THE END
OF THE UNDERSERVED- UNDER OUR
RESOURCE AREA. EXACTLY OKAY IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY SAME SORT OF
STORY- HERE AGAIN H. B. I'VE
WANTED TO ARE YOU SEE ON OUR
OFFICE CENTRAL- EAST LOT EAST
OAKLAND THIS IS UP THROUGH- UP
THE THROUGHA THIRTY TOWARD
RICH MAN AND BUT MOSTLY DOWN IN
THE CORNER OF OAKLAND A
PROMINENT AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY ASIAN COMMUNITY- AND
YOU SEE ALL HIGH RISK LOW.
VACCINATION NUMBERS NEXT LIKELY.
BUT BUILT. LIGHT GREEN- DOT IS
THE SITE AT THE OAKLAND
COLISEUM END UP LIKE THE DARKER
GREENS ARE THE MOBILE SITES
THAT WE PLAY STRATEGICALLY I
BET WORKING WITH C. B. HOURS
AND THE COUNTY OFFICE OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO BE ABLE TO GET THESE.
IMPLEMENTED OKAY SO THIS IS
THREE FIFTEEN NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
THREE TWENTY FOUR NICE START TO
SEE THINGS TURN PRETTY GREEN
AND GLASS READ THREE NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. THREE THIRTY. ALMOST
ALL GREEN- IT'S KIND OF IN THE
MIDDLE BETWEEN THE RED AND THE
AND THE AND THE AND THE LIGHT
GREEN THAT'S LIKELY TO. THAT'S
WHAT WE- RIGHT AND SO YOU SEE
WE'VE NOW MOVED INTO THE HIGH
RISK HIGH VACCINATION- AREA AND
IN MANY CASES YOU'RE SEEING A
HIGH RISK A LOW RISK HIGH
VACCINATION AS WE FLIPPED OUT
SOME OF THESE COMMUNITIES ARE
ENSURING THAT WE'RE GETTING A
GOOD PENETRATION OF
VACCINATION. EXACTLY OKAY I
THINK THAT'S IT. SO A STRONG
CONNECTION BETWEEN CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES THAT THE
EMERGENCY RESPONSE NETWORKS KEY
TO BUILDING OUT THE BETTER
PLANNING AND PREPAREDNESS FOR
DISASTERS AND SWIFTLY MEETING
IMMUNITY NEEDS DURING AND AFTER
EMERGENCY EVENTS FOR EXAMPLE.
HELLO YES IS LEAST BILLS
PROGRAM WE DELIVERED EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS INFORMATION THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES THROUGH
LOCAL ASSISTANCE GRANTS WHICH
ARE ISSUED TO CBO'S THE FUNDING
DELIVERY OF IMPORTANT EMERGENCY
INFORMATION IN A MANNER THEY
DETERMINE IS THE MOST EFFECTIVE.
UNDERSTANDABLE AND TIMELY CBO'S
ARE GIVEN THIS RESPONSIBILITY
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE TRUST OF
THE COMMUNITY ACTOR COMMUNICATE
IN THE MOST CULTURALLY
COMPETENT WAY. AT THE ONSET OF
THE CORPORATE NINETEEN WE WORK
TO SIMPLY. SIMPLIFY PUBLIC
HEALTH MESSAGING. AND MAKE THEM
MORE ACCESSIBLE FOR THE PUBLIC
AND VULNERABLE GROUPS WITH
INFORMATIONAL PRINT AND ONLINE
MATERIALS AND SOCIAL MEDIA
GRAPHICS. THE COORDINATED
STATEWIDE COMMUNICATIONS
STRATEGY IMPLEMENTED BY THE
CAMPAIGN REACHED A BROADER
AUDIENCE OF ORGANIZATIONS
VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS AND
OTHER KEY STAKEHOLDERS TARGETED
BY THE CAMPAIGN. IN CLOSING
NATURAL DISASTERS AND PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCIES DO NOT.
IMPACT ALL CALIFORNIANS THE
SAME THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC MADE THAT PAINFULLY
OBVIOUS. FORTUNATELY THE NEWS
MINISTRATION. HAS MADE EQUITY
FOR VALUE AND FUNDAMENTAL TO
ITS FUNCTIONS. HELLO YOU HAVE
HAS EQUITY DEBATE THE INTO WITH
THE RESPONSE AND RECOVERY
CONSTRUCTS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS THE GROWING INTENSITY
AND FREQUENCY OF WILDFIRES THE
LOOMING THREAT OF THE NEXT BIG
EARTHQUAKE AND ESPECIALLY THE
THREAT OF A NEW PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY IN A MANNER THAT IS
EQUITABLE FAIR. AND ENSURES THE
MOST VULNERABLE AMONG US ARE
ADEQUATELY PREPARED AND
PROTECTED. I WANT TO THANK YOU
ALL FOR OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
BEFORE YOU TODAY AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO ENSURING
STRONG AND EQUITABLE
PREPAREDNESS AND RESPONSE TO
THIS PANDEMIC. TO ANSWERING
QUESTIONS ONE THANK YOUR
DIRECTOR AND THANK ALL OF THE
PARTICIPANTS FOR THEIR TIME AND
TESTIMONY IN TODAY'S ARE
HEARING. US WITHOUT WILL BRING
IT BACK TO. THE COMMITTEE FOR
OF MEMBERS QUESTIONS I HAVE A
TWO QUESTIONS SO- ONE FROM I'M
A LITTLE CONFUSED ON THE
NUMBERS REGARDING. THE
EQUITABLE OF- ISSUE. INEQUITIES
WERE HAVING ENOUGH DISTANT
COMMUNITIES NO A DOCTOR ARE
GOING TALKED ABOUT FORTY ONLY
46% OF THOSE AREAS HAVE BEEN
VACCINATED BUT THEN AGAIN
LOOKING AT THE COLOR CHART IT
SEEMS LIKE IT'S A DIFFERENT
BIKE THAT NUMBER SHOULD BE LIKE
IT'S 70% RYE BROOK C. THAT THE
COLOR CHANGES HAVE REALLY
CHANGED A LOT SO THAT REALLY
HAS ME A LITTLE CONFUSED ON
WHAT REALLY IS ARE THE
PERCENTAGE BECAUSE I'M HEARING
ONE NUMBER BUT THAT I'M SEEING
A COLOR CHART THAT LOOKS
TOTALLY DIFFERENT BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY THOUGH THOSE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WERE
THE HARDEST HIT WE CAN ALL
AGREE. AND WE'RE DOING A LOT
BETTER NOW BUT I'M JUST LOOKING
FEES REGARDING THE COLOR CHART
THE PERCENTAGE THAT'S ONE
QUESTIONAND THE SECOND
QUESTION I JUST HAD IS
REGARDING- THE STATEWIDE PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS REGARDING
GREAT PLATES DELIVERED. AND
PROJECT ROOM KAY I'M JUST ON
THAT NOTE JUST WANTED TO SEE IF
THOSE. HAVE BEEN OF THOSE
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN ADOPTED IN
EVERY COUNTY IN THE STATE SO.
WITHOUT ANYBODY CAN AFTER THOSE
TWO. MAYBE THIS IS DOCTOR ERICA
MAYBE I'LL TAKE THE FIRST ONE.
SO IF YOU IF YOU GO TO THE
GOVERNOR'S WEBSITE COVED
NINETEEN DOT CA DOT GOV. AND
THERE'S A LINK THERE THAT WILL
TAKE YOU TO THE FACT THE BACK
AT THE TOP OF THE RIGHT HAND
SIDE THE TICKET A VACCINE. THE
VACCINE DATA. AND IF YOU GO
THERE YOU'LL YOU'LL GET TO SEE
THEM. THAT BREAK OUT WHERE I
GOT THAT THE THAT THE
STATISTICS NE OF THE THINGS
THAT'S ALWAYS A LITTLE BIT
CONFUSING WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
STATISTICS. IS THAT THERE'S TWO
MAJOR STATISTICS THAT THEY'LL
GIVE YOU THEY WILL SAY. OF ALL
THE VACCINES THAT WERE GIVEN
WHAT PROPORTIONS WENT INTO
DIFFERENT QUARTILES THE H. BACK
QUARTILES. SO THAT'S ONE TYPE
OF STATISTIC. ED- AND YOU'LL
END IT THAT'S THERE FOR FROM
THAT'S DIFFERENT FROM THAT WHAT
I'M ABOUT TO SAY MAXES OUT WITH
WITHIN A QUARTILE. WITHIN A
QUARTILE OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE. WHAT PROPORTION HAVE
BEEN VACCINATED. A THAT GETS
CONFUSING. BOTH BOTH OF THOSE
THE TWO THINGS ARE IMPORTANT
STATISTICS ONE GIVE AN IDEA OF
THE ALLOCATION AND THE OTHER
ONE GIVES THE SECOND ONE GIVES
YOU THE IDEA OF COVERAGE WITHIN
A QUARTILE. AND THEY'RE BOTH
IMPORTANT BUT THEY CAN BE VERY
CONFUSING AND IT'S UP IF YOU
CAN BE A CHALLENGE. SO OFF FROM
THE FROM THE WEBSITE WHAT YOU
WILL SEE IS. WITH VAN QUARTILE
ONE OF THE WITHIN QUARTILE ONE
FOR VACCINE COVERAGE FOR
VACCINE COVERAGE FORTY SEVEN
POINT 1% HAVE RECEIVED AT LEAST
ONE DOES- WITH AGAIN WITH AND
WITHIN THAT QUARTILE TWENTY
NINE POINT 6% ARE FULLY
VACCINATED. THAT MEANS THAT
THERE'S 53% OF ELIGIBLE PEOPLE
THE COURTHOUSE IN INDIO
COURTHOUSE ACROSS THE STATE
THAT STILL NEED TO BE
VACCINATED. NOW WITHIN THE
HIGHEST QUARTILE HIGH SINGLE
QUARTET WHICH IS QUARTILE FOR.
71% HAVE RECEIVED SEVENTY ONE
POINT 4% HAVE RECEIVED- AT
LEAST ONE SOUTH. 47% OF THOSE
ARE FULLY VACCINATED AND THAT
MEANS THAT THERE'S A REMAINDER
OF ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT POINT SIX
PERCENT. SO THAT'S THAT'S THE
REAL DISPARITY THAT THAT'S
ACTUALLY THE MOST IMPORTANT A
SEVERITY TO FOCUS ON AT THE END
OF THE DAY IS WHAT IS THE
COVERAGE. I MEAN THAT'S WHY
THERE'S SUCH A BIG FOCUS ON
QUARTILE ONE IS BECAUSE WE
WANTED WE WANTED WE WOULD LIKE
IT TO BE AS HIGH AS QUARTILE
FOR THE HIGHER INCOME. TO ALL
IN THERE THANK YOU. OKAY FIFTY
S. NOT AND SO THIS IS UP SMART
DR ARE GONNA. ALWAYS HELPFUL- I
DON'T ALSO- SO I THINK DOCTOR
ARE GONE LOOK- IN THE AGGREGATE
BROUGHT. ACROSS THIS AND ARE
EFFORTS WERE VERY. IN TWO-
COMMUNITY VERY HI COMMITTEE-
ADD THAT THE- THOSE THOSE. IN
THE THOSE FOLKS. BEEN CUT BY.
ABOUT THE LARGER NUMBERS BY
COMPARISON TO SOME OF THESE
TARGETED AREAS IN THE MISSION
THAT. WE HAD- YOU'RE GONNA SEE
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT NUMBERS
IT'S A IT'S A MUCH MORE
FOCUSED. OUR AREA CONCENTRATED
THERE IF YOU WOULD THAT'S BE
ABLE TO OPPORTUNITY FOR US THAT.
OP ACTUALLY NUMBERS. AND I AM
I'M SORRY- SOME I DIDN'T CATCH
YOUR SECOND QUESTION. ARE THE
SUB ONE WAS REGARDING THE
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS SUCH
AS GREAT PLATES DELIVERED AND
PROJECT ROOM K. DISTRICTS HAVE
THEY BEEN ADOPTED IN EVERY
COUNTY OF THE STATE. YEAH SO
THAT WELL BUT THE PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM IS BEEN LAID
OVER IN EVERY COUNTY IN THE
STATE AND THAT OF COURSE IS YOU
KNOW THEY- THE OP THE PRIVATE
MINISTRATION MADE AND SHIPPED-
AND- BUT MAKE SURE THAT THE
THESE THESE ELIGIBLE PROGRAMS
WE'RE GOING TO BE REIMBURSED AT
ONE HUNDRED PERCENT- AND- IT
WAS NOT THE CASE WHEN WE
STARTED THE. PANDEMIC IT WAS AT
A COST- BUT NOW IS AND HOW 2%
AND IT'S AND THOSE CAN THAT WE
DON'T- YES AS WE- WITH
EVERYTHING IN THE STATE WERE
WORKING WITH US SAT REPUBLICAN
CITIES WORKING WITH EACH OTHER
CAL ADMITTED. ARE TO BE OVER-
BUT THERE BY THEIR THIRD LOOK
LIKE IF THE SO MANY OF THE
COUNTIES HAVE NEEDED TO GET-
EXPEDITE FUNDING THAT WE HAVE
WERE THAT THE EX BUT I FOR AND
THEIR- EDITOR BY SO IT HELP
THEM BALANCE ALL- AND- YOU KNOW
IN THE CASE OF GREAT PLACE WELL
I WANTED TO MENTION THAT. THAT
YOU KNOW GREAT PLACE PROGRAM
WAS WAS WAS PRETTY. IT WAS A
DOUBLE BENEFIT REALLY IT WAS
THE- I CAN'T TROUBLED BY. IF
NOT ONLY PROVIDED. THAT TO
EITHER SURE OR SENIOR THAT
COULD GET OUT. IT A LOT IT WAS
RUN. LOCAL REST IN THE- SO I
FOR. RESTAURANTS THE- TO WE- UP
ED KEEP FLOW AND BUT IF I ALLOW-
RESTAURANTS KEEP PEOPLE IN. SO
WE GOT A- WE HAVE A REST THE
STATE OF. BOB AND WE WERE ABLE
TO SERVE MEALS- ACROSS THE
BOARD AND- AND AGAIN. FOR DATA
THROUGH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BOTH.
BOTH ROOM HE AND A GREAT PLACE.
AND HOW HARPER HARPER'S
HOUSING. FOR THE HARVEST. ALL
ALL ALL WOULD BE UNDER THE
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. AND-
AND L. FOR COUNTIES TO GET
RECOUP COST. THANK YOU I THINK
OF COURSE BY MEMBER DR YOU
QUESTION YEAH GOOD. THANK YOU
FOR THE PRESS- SO MUCH OF MY
DAY DEPENDENT ON TOURISM AND
THE INDUSTRY- AND WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE FULL RE OPENING.
ON JUNE FIFTEENTH. DO YOU KNOW
IF CALIFORNIANS DOES CALIFORNIA
NEED TO REACH ANY PARTICULAR
METRICS IN ORDER TO FULLY OPEN
ON JUNE FIFTEENTH OR IF WE WILL
CONTINUE THE TREND THE WAY WE
ARE. WILL THAT BE ENOUGH TO GET
THE FULL RE OPENING. SO CURRENT
CURRENTLY YEAH THE IN TERMS OF
THE METRICS WERE LOOKING
PRIMARILY AT THE VACCINATION
COVERAGE AND THE DISEASE-
OUTCOMES. IN TERMS OF CASES
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND DEATHS. AS
A STATE OVERALL WE'RE DOING
FANTASTIC. AND IN TERMS OF
VACCINATIONS WERE ALSO DOING
VERY WELL. AND THE OTHER THING
I WANT TO ADD IS THAT THE FACT
THAT THERE'S THAT THERE'S A
VACCINE COVERAGE WHICH GIVES
IMMUNITY. BUT THERE'S ALSO A
PROPORTION OF THE POPULATION
THAT HAD NATURAL INFRACTION
INFECTION. SO THEY HAVE SOME OF
THE MUNITY FROM THE NATURAL
INFECTION SO WHEN YOU COMBINE
ALL THAT UP- THE PROPORTION OF
PEOPLE THAT HAVE- COMMUNITY
RIGHT DOWN THE STATE IS GOING
UP. SO WE'RE MOVING WERE
ABSOLUTELY MOVING IN THE IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AND THAT IT
WILL BE A TRANSITION PERIOD. WE
WANT THAT THE RATES TO CONTINUE
TO BE AS LOW AS LOW AS POSSIBLE
BECAUSE THAT MAKES HIGHER RISK
ACTIVITIES. A SAFER. I DURING
THIS TRANSITION PERIOD WILL
CONTINUE TO ASK PEOPLE TO WEAR
A MASK ESPECIALLY INTO INDOORS.
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER JEFF QUESTION. YES I
MEAN JUST A COMMON AND SEEMS
LIKE WE STILL I THINK HAVE A
LONG WAY TO GO AND SPECIFICALLY
REACHING OUT TO LATINO
COMMUNITY- IN AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES- SEE THAT PROGRESS
IS BEING MADE BUT I THINK ONE.
ONE THING I WOULD KNOW IS- I
THINK THE IMPORTANCE OF GO AND
I THINK- DR PERASAAN- MADE THIS
POINT I THINK IT'S A GOOD ONE
AS YOU KIND OF YOU NEED TO BE
GOING TO THE PLACES THAT THEY
ARE YOU KNOW AND I THINK THE
CHURCH IS A GREAT EXAMPLE OF
WHERE THAT REALLY WORKED WELL-
ONE THING I DIDN'T REALLY HEAR
FROM ANYBODY IS WHERE WERE OUR
FOLKS IN LIKE IN THE VALLEY.
ESPECIALLY THE CENTRAL VALLEY-
I KNOW WE HAD THESE MOBILE
CLINICS AND I'VE BEEN IN
OAKLAND AND LA- BUT I HAVEN'T
SEEN LIKE WHERE IT'S BEEN A
REAL FOCUS THE OUT REACH. FOR
EXISTENCE IS TO THE FARMWORKER
COMMUNITY- AND I REALLY THINK
IT IT'S A MATTER WHAT I'VE SEEN
SOME OF THE BEST PROGRAMS THAT
ARE DONE REALLY AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL- YOLO COUNTY I THINK FOR
EXAMPLE- AND OTHERS HAVE REALLY
TRIED TO FOCUS ON HOW DO WE GO
OUT. ACTUALLY TO- THE COMMUNITY
WHERE THEY'RE AT WHERE THEY
LIVE WHERE THEY WORK. TO REALLY-
NEIL- ENSURE THAT THEY GET
VACCINATED ARE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO AN ACCESS TO I
THINK HAVING THE REALLY LARGE
EVENTS WHERE YOU COME COME TO A
PLACE TO ME IT JUST FROM THE
OBSERVATION DON'T SEEM TO BE
WORKING AS WELL LIKE GETTING TO
VACCINATING THESE COMMUNITIES
ARE THEY GONNA DO A LITTLE MORE
OUT REACH TO WHERE WHERE
THEY'RE THERE AT- SO MAYBE W.
ONE THING IS JUST HAVE. YOU
GUYS RESPOND TO THAT- HAS THERE
BEEN ANY REAL FOCUS ON. ON THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IN TERMS OF
DOING MORE OUTREACH- I HEARD
THE OTHER MOBILE CLINICS IN THE
AND- MORE URBAN PARTS OF THE
STATE BUT- HOW ABOUT IN SOME OF
THE OTHER AREAS OF THE STATE.
YEAH THIS IS DOCTOR ERIC I'LL
TAKE A FIRST SHOT YEAH. YES SIR
THERE HAVE THERE HAVE BEEN
EFFORTS. BUT THAT OF COURSE IF
IT'S NOT ENOUGH IT'S SO THAT'S
WHY THEY'RE REAP REDOUBLING
EFFORTS. OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
ACTUALLY MAYBE SOMETIME THIS
WEEK THIS WEEK- WILL BE
ANNOUNCING ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE
IMPLEMENTED. THERE IS GOING TO
BE A FOCUS ON. THIRTEEN
COUNTIES. WHERE WERE REALLY
YEAH THAT'S GOING TO INCLUDE
AREAS LIKE A FRESNO KERN BUT
THERE MADERA- MERCED RIVERSIDE
SAN BERNARDINO SAN JOAQUIN
STANISLAUS. INTO LARI SO WE ARE
GONNA BE DOUBLING UP OUR
EFFORTS AND IT'S REALLY A IT'S
REALLY AS A STATE AND LOCAL
PARTNERSHIP BECAUSE REALLY IT'S
THE PEOPLE ON THE GROUND. IF
THE CHURCHES IF THE CBO'S IF
THE SCHOOLS. WITH A PARTNERSHIP
BECAUSE YOU REALLY HAVE TO GET
REALLY HAVE TO WORK WITH THE
COMMUNITY TO BUILD TO BUILD
TRUST. UNDER IT THE STATE BY
ITSELF CANNOT CANNOT DO IT. AND
IT'S GONNA BE DIFFERENT THAN
EVERY DIFFERENT LOCATION
BECAUSE THE EVERY EVERY
COMMUNITIES VERY VERY DIFFERENT
BUT- YOU WILL SEE MORE EFFORTS
YOU'LL SEE MORE EFFORTS IN THAT
AREA OF MARDAN MOBILE CLINICS-
THAT THERE IS THE HOME BROWN
PROGRAM THAT YOU HEARD YOU
HEARD ABOUT- FROM AND STUFF. SO
STAY TUNED. FOR THE NEXT THE
NEXT THAT A FEW WEEKS. MY EVERY
MARKET ME JUST. DR GONE FOREVER
AT THE EXIT AFTER OF WORK AYE
LET'S NOT LOSE SIGHT OF THE
FACT THAT THERE IS A HUGE HUGE
EFFORT IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
TASK FORCE THAT WENT ON. DURING
THE HEIGHT OF THE COLD BAD-
THAT THAT REALLY TRY TO FOCUS
ON THE HIGH CASE RATES AND
MORBIDITY OF THE CENTRAL
WORKERS THE ACT WORKERS- BUILT
THE LATINO POPULATION THE DRESS
THE ISSUES THAT THE- TASK FORCE
WAS. CREATED TO FOCUS ON FOR
BETTER OUTCOMES IN THESE
COUNTIES AND IT WAS ENGAGE WITH
WITH THAT CBO'S- WITH- WITH
GROUPS REPRESENTING-
FARMWORKERS- REPORTER AND
BUSINESS OWNERS FARMERS. ARE
WITH HOSPITALS AND WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH ENTITIES ARE WITHIN
THOSE- WITHIN THE REGION BOB
THE EIGHT COUNTIES- AND WE DID
A SIMILAR THING IN IMPERIAL
COUNTY AS WELL BECAUSE OF THE
GROWING SEASON THERE AND OF
COURSE WE HAD CHALLENGES
IMPERIAL COUNTY BECAUSE OF THE
HIGH. QUALITY OF INDIVIDUALS
THE CROSS THAT LIVE IN MEXICO
AND CROSS THE BORDER FOR COMING
TO WORK IN IMPERIAL COUNTY IN
THE FIELDS AND IT'S A CRITICAL
AT ENTITY A CRITICAL ELEMENT
BECAUSE IT'S SUCH AN IMPORTANT
FOOD SUPPLY AND SO WE HADN'T
REALLY PUT A LOT OF EFFORT AND
IT OF COURSE IMPERIAL COUNTY
HAVE HIGH CASE. RATE NUMBERS
AND SO IT WAS A THERE IS NOT
JUST A CONCERTED EFFORT OF
ADDRESSING- YOU KNOW THE
EDUCATION BUT BUT EVERYTHING
FROM MEDICATION P. P. ZERO UP
SETTING UP ALTERNATIVE CARE
SITES TO US THE QUESTIONING
FOLKS TO- OF METERING THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT COME IN.
OUR AND UP FOR SETTING UP THIS
STUFF HARVEST HOTEL FOR HARVEST
WORKERS TO BE ABLE THAT TWO
SEPARATE WAS DIFFICULT BECAUSE
OF THE CULTURE. OF THESE
COMMUNITIES CULTURE THE
FAMILIESIS AS A FAMILY THE
STAY GATHER. AND THAT WAS ONE
THE ISSUE THAT WE TO DO A LOT
OF IT YOU. WHAT TRUST THE
SOURCES TO BE ABLE. ADDRESS
THAT SO I WILL JUST TELL YOU
THAT. OVER TIME THE- MEDICAID
THAT WE PUT IT. THE OPERATIVE
BOTH IMPERIAL AND CENTRAL
VALLEY HAVE A HUGE IMPACT AND
DID DID. IT MAKE THE TURN- AND
HELP TO ADDRESS IT BUT THE
DOCTOR ARE BONDS POINTS THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S ONGOING AND
NEEDS TO. CONTINUE TO HELP
APPLY AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN THE
COMING MONTHS. NO AND I
APPRECIATE THAT I WAS REALLY
MORE FOCUSING AND NARROWING IN
ON VACCINATIONS. AND YOU KNOW
THAT'S WHERE I THINK WE JUST
HAVE. WE GOT A LOT MORE WORK TO
DO. AND I THINK LIKE IN OUR
LAST HEARING I THINK IT WAS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY THAT ARE
BROUGHT UP THAT YOU KNOW THERE
WAS. YOU KNOW YEAH. YOU KNOW
EXPONENTIALLY MORE UNITS MOBILE
UNITS IN SOME OF THE MORE URBAN
AREAS AND NOT. NOT AS MANY IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY DO YOU KNOW
IF THAT IS CHANGED BECAUSE I.
AGAIN I THINK THE REAL.
EMPHASIS NEEDS TO BE ON OUT
REACHING GOING TO. YOU KNOW
WHERE PEOPLE ARE AT AND SO I
YOU KNOW I. I REALLY THINK WE
NEED TO DO THAT IN ORDER TO
IMPROVE OUR NUMBERS- ON AN
EQUITY BASIS OF REACHING ALL-
DEMOGRAPHICS IN IN IN THE
STATE- I WILL SAY I'M GREAT
PLATES I KNOW THERE WAS A LOT
OF FANFARE ABOUT IT. I CAN TELL
YOU MY COMMUNITY WE DIDN'T SEE
WE HARDLY SOUGHT- I DON'T KNOW
OF ANY RESTAURANTS THAT TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT- SO I MEAN I.
I SEE HOW WHERE MAYBE IT WORKED
AND IN CERTAIN AREAS BUT I
DON'T. I THINK THE COMMITTEE
ASKED FOR DATE ON EVERY COUNTY.
AND I DON'T THINK LEAST WE
STILL HAVEN'T REALLY RECEIVED
THAT INFORMTION ABOUT HEY HOW
HOW BROADLY WAS THIS MADE IN.
AND THAT'S BEEN JUST ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS I THINK- IN DEALING
WITH THE GOVERNOR DURING THIS
IS. WE GET SOME BIG
ANNOUNCEMENT ABOUT SOME PROGRAM
IS GOING TO BE. AMAZING AND
I'LL TELL YOU A LOT OF PARTS OF
THE STATE DON'T REALLY SEE THAT
EVER ACTUALLY COME TO FRUITION.
THAT'S NOT TO UNDERMINE THE
WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE BUT
ASSIST. I YOU KNOW WHEN IT WHEN
I SEE IT LIKE- THIS WAS
EVERYWHERE AND IT WAS SO GREAT
FOR ALL PARTS OF THE STATE I
MEAN. WE DIDN'T SEE IT. SO AND
I DO THINK IT'S- YOU'LL BE GOOD
TO GET THAT DATA. NOW WHERE WAS
A SAD AND EACH EACH PART OF THE
STATE COUNTY BY COUNTY- AND
LOOK I MEAN. AGAIN I DON'T WANT
TO HAD I REALLY DON'T WANT TO
BE NEGATIVE I THINK THERE HAS
BEEN SUBSTANTIAL PROGRESS I
WILL REITERATE THAT AGAIN BUT
WE STILL HAVE TO I THINK YOU
ARE. A BETTER JOB OF GETTING TO
ALL PARTS OF THE STATE AND ALL
DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE STATE- AND
RIGHT NOW THE FOCUS IS JUST GOT
TO BE ON VACCINATIONS RIGHT AND
ENSURING THAT- WE'RE WE'RE
REALLY GETTING TO THESE
POPULATIONS. MR QUICK COMMENT
HAVE A ONE MORE COMMON VIA SOME
VICE CHAIR CERTAIN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- IN A KIND OF PIGGY
BACKING ON. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER'S COMMENTS. YOU KNOW
THE MOST EQUITABLE AND WE'VE
SAID THIS YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN-KIND OF SAYING THIS FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING. THE MOST
EQUITABLE APPROACH. TO DEALING
WITH A PANDEMIC. IS TO GET AS
MANY PEOPLE VACCINATED AS
POSSIBLE IN THE SHORTEST AMOUNT
OF TIME. BECAUSE THAT COVERS
EVERYBODY AND THAT'S AS MANY
PEOPLE WHO ARE WILLING TO GET
IT. AND RIGHT I AT THE
BEGINNING THERE WAS A SUPPLY
ISSUE AND WE'RE TRYING TO
BALANCE OUT WELL IT'S YOU KNOW
A LITTLE BIT HERE AND A LITTLE
BIT THERE WE DON'T WANT ANYBODY
GET END OF EACH OTHER. AND IT
REALLY SLOW THE PROCESS DOWN.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE SEEING. A
SUPPLIER VACCINATIONS THAT WE
HAVE MORE SUPPLY THAN DEMAND
PROBABLY. AND AND SO NOW IS IT
IS THE TIME THAT THIS THIS
OUTREACH IS SUPER IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE ANYBODY HAS BEEN LEFT
BEHIND. HAS THE OPPORTUNITY IF
WE GIVE IT TO ARM TO GO DO THAT
AND MR GALLAGHER IS ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT WE GOT TO GO OUT THERE
AND GET THAT. NOW THAT WE HAVE
THAT. AND NOT ONLY THAT BUT AS
OTHERS GET. THE OTHER PEOPLE
THAT MAY NOT FALL INTO THOSE
CATEGORIES- GET VACCINATED-THEY- THEY CREATE LESS EXPOSURE
FOR THOSE THAT DO FALL INTO
THOSE CATEGORIES. WHEN THEY'RE
AT THE MARKET WHEN THEY'RE AT-
WHATEVER OTHER EVENTS ARE OUT
THERE- WHEN THEY'RE WALKING
AROUND AT DISNEYLAND- OR OR ANY
OTHER THINGS WERE MASS CROWDS
GRABBED THE BEACH. SO ALL OF
THAT HELPS CONTRIBUTE TO WHAT
OUR MAIN GOAL HAS TO BE IN A
PANDEMIC. WHICH IS GET AS MANY
PEOPLE WHO WANT VACCINATIONS
VACCINATED AS FAST AS POSSIBLE.
AND THEN AT THE END WE'RE ABLE
TO GATHER THOSE THAT HAD THE
HESITANCY THEY WERE SLOWING THE
PROCESS DOWN WE CAN LET THE
PROCESS GETS SLOW DOWN LIKE
THAT. SO THAT'S IT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YOU GUYS APPRECIATE
ALL THE INFORMATION TODAY.
THANK YOU WITHOUT TO QUICK
QUESTIONS REGARDING ONE
REGARDING- VACCINE HESITANCY IN
THE FACT THAT- ONE THING JUST
CAME TO MIND MY SON ACTUALLY
WORKS AT A- TESTING FACILITY
DOWN IN L. A. COUNTY NEEDS
TELLING ME TODAY THAT- BECAUSE
THEY'RE SOLD OVER TURNOUT FOR
FOLKS GETTING TESTED THAT THERE
ARE CLOSE IN ONE DAY OUT OF THE
WEEK SO. JUST CHRIS ARE WHAT
ARE THE PLANS TO GET MORE FOLKS
OUT THERE TO GET TESTED. AND
WHAT ARE WE DOING REGARDING-
FOLKS THAT ARE STILL HAS A TEN
REGARDING VACCINES ANYTHING NEW
THAT WE'RE GOING TO DO. TO
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES. SO A
COUPLE OF THINGS YES SO WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE- THE STATE IS VERY
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING
TESTING. AND WHAT YOU WILL SEE
IS THAT SO WE HAVE A TESTING
PROGRAM THAT'S GOING TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE TESTING. TO
THE WORK FORCE AND TO SCHOOLS.
AND THEN TO CONTINUE TO MAKE IT
AVAILABLE ACROSS THE STATE WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S-
THERE'S- THERE'S GOING TO
CONTINUE TO BE RISK FOR PEOPLE
BECOMING INFECTED BECAUSE THE
VACCINE IS NOT A HUNDRED
PERCENT. WHERE PEOPLE ARE A BY.
IN THERE RIGHT NOW. POPULATIONS
THAT ARE NOT ELIGIBLE SO WEAK
WE EXPECT TO CONTINUE TO SEE
CASES OF TESTING WILL WILL
CONTINUE. AND WILL CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT AND. INFRASTRUCTURE
YEAH THE REASON WHY THAT'S
REALLY AND- IS BECAUSE OF THE
VERY. WE NEED TO HAVE. ON HOW
THE VIRUS IS EVOLVING. TO SEE
THAT GETTING AROUND IT'S
GETTING AROUND- OUR OUR OUR
VACCINES OR ARE AN IMMUNITY.
AND THEN THE SECOND THING ABOUT
VACCINE HESITANCY- YES YOU WE
ARE WE ARE THE YOU'LL SEE OVER
THE COMING WEEKS. YOU'LL SEE A
DOUBLING UP ON EFFORTS TO
REALLY DO OUTRAGE TO THE
DIFFERENT THAT. DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES OF CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA. NOT JUST A CARPET
CAMPAIGN BUT ALSO THE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH LOCAL
ENTITIES. TO REALLY REACH THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT AS HAS ALREADY
BEEN DESCRIBED. IT'S IT HAS TO
BE VERY IT HAS TO BE VERY LOCAL
YOU HAVE TO GO INTO THE
COMMUNITY. AND YOU HAVE TO HAVE
TRUSTED. TRUSTED MESSENGERS AND
TRUSTED SITES WHERE PEOPLE FEEL
COMFORTABLE. AND SO THAT'LL
THAT'LL BE. THE EFFORT IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE LOCALS.
WITH THE ANYMORE COURSE. C.
WANT TO THANK OUR ALL OF OUR
PARTICIPANTS FOR YOUR PROVIDING
YOUR TIME TESTIMONY ON THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE. AND WITH
THAT- SO BEFORE WE CLOSE I WANT
TO GO TO OUR PUBLIC COMMENT
SECTION. I'M NOT SURE IF
ANYBODY HAS CALLED IN REGARDING
PUBLIC COMMENT- WITH THAT SAID
WILL GO AHEAD- WITH OPERATOR IF
THERE'S ANYBODY ON THE LINE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. AND WITHOUT
SAID- FOLKS WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES ONLY FOR PUBLIC
COMMENTS OPERATOR. DO WE HAVE
ANYONE ON THE LINE. THANK YOU
YES WE DO AND AGAIN IT'S ONE
ZERO. WE'LL GO FIRST TO LIE
NUMBER FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE MOMENT HERE THEY TOOK
THEMSELVES OUT HERE WILL GO
BACK. NOW WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IT'S CARE HAS GONE TOO
FAR FIRST YOU CONVINCE ISN'T%
SCHOOL FOR VIRUS THAT IS A
NINETY NINE POINT 9% SURVIVAL
RATE. THEN MAKE EVERYONE WEAR
MASKS WHO JUST LIKE USING
ENTERTAINMENT THANKS TO KEEP
MOSQUITOES OUT NEXT TEST
EVERYONE. WAS AN INACCURATE
BOGUS. ALL THE TIME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WE CAN GRAB GO
BACK HERE TO LINE FOURTEEN IF I
HAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. THANK YOU THIS IS
KATHY BURKE WITH THE HEALTH
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA I REALLY APPRECIATE
ALL THE QUESTIONS THAT THEY
ABOUT HOW WE CAN DO BETTER IN
THE FUTURE AND HOW WE CAN USE
LESSONS LEARNED. ONE OF THE
WAYS YOU CAN USE THE LESSONS
LEARNED DURING THIS PANDEMIC IF
TO MAKE SURE THAT LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ARE PREPARED FOR
THE NEXT PANDEMIC BY MAKING
SURE THEY'RE FULLY FUNDED AND
WE HAVE A BILL THIS YEAR TO
STUDY WHAT LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS NEED AND ALSO A
BUDGET REQUEST FOR ON GOING
GENERAL FUNDING. TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ARE FULLY STAFFED
AND READY TO FACE THE NEXT
EMERGENCY WHEN. IT ARISES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU OPERATOR
WOMEN'S. WE DO GIVE ME JUST ONE
MOMENT HERE WILL GO ONLINE AND
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE TWENTY FOUR AM I LYING
TWENTY FOUR. YES YOU ARE YEAH-
EXCELLENT. I JUST WANTED TO
SHARE A BIT OF INFORMATION-
FROM A NEWS STORY FROM
SEPTEMBER NINTH KCRA. DR ANNE
SISSON PLASTER COUNTY PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICER- RESIGN AND
SUBMITTED HER LETTER OF
RESIGNATION ON TUESDAY.
SEPTEMBER NINTH AFTER THE
PLASTER COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS VOTED UNANIMOUSLY
TO END THE LOCAL CODE NINETEEN
HEALTH EMERGENCY WHICH THE
BOARD PUT IN PLACE AMID THE
PANDEMIC IN MARCH. SO YOUR
EXPERT TODAY DR AMY SUSSMAN
SAYING THAT THE CHILDREN WILL
BE VACCINATED BASICALLY. GO TO
THE NEXT ONE DOWN UNDER LAST
JOB WHEN THE PEOPLE TOOK CHARGE
AND DECIDED. THAT THE OPERATING.
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YEAH I'M GLAD TO CALL AND TALK
TO ALL OF YOU YOU WILL NOT BE
VACCINATING THE CHILDREN YOUR
HOME HIGHER PLAN THAT MAKE HAVE
COMPLETELY FALLEN APART YOU ARE
DISGUISING EVERYTHING YOU'RE
DOING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MCCARTY CAN CALL THE NEXT
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THERE. I'D LIKE TO REALLY
CARE GRADUATE ALL THE PEOPLE
THAT THE UNITED NOT TO GET
VACCINATED. RIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OPERATING UNDER THE
NEXT ONE. OVER LINE NUMBER
TWENTY SEVEN. IS THAT ME YEP.
HI MY NAME IS KATHERINE MCBRIDE
AND I WANTED TO TELL YOU ABOUT
MY CAM NEWTON AND EXCITEMENT
YOU SCIENTISTS THE VISOR IT WAS
STATED THAT ITIS NOW TOO LATE
TO SAVE ANY PERSON'S BEEN
INJECTED WITH ANY CODE NINETEEN
SIXTEEN HE URGES THOSE WHO HAVE
NOT BEEN YET BEEN INJECTED THE
DEADLINE THURMOND JUST
BIPARTISAN. HUMANS AND THE
LIVES OF. THEIR CHILDREN. A
MOMENT HERE. ENDOPHYTIC AND-
OFFERS NO ONE ELSE ON THE LINE.
NO FURTHER COMMENT AND WITH
THAT SAID. I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY ONCE AGAIN FOR
PARTICIPATING ALL THE FOLKS
THAT. WERE HERE TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY AND WITH THAT THIS
HEARING IS ADJOURNED THANK YOU.